the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
the 2023 Grand chess tour kicked off an
illustrious fashion with the super bet
chess classic in Bucharest Romania the
world's best players were treated to all
of the pop and Circumstance befitting
the world's Premier chess tour Wesley so
got things started by defeating reigning
GCT Champa lareza farrugia in a come
from behind Victory to take the early
lead so stayed near the top of the field
throughout the event but his lead was
short-lived as his fellow country meant
Fabiano caruana quickly took the reins
after winning two straight games French
number one a la Reza farrugia went on a
hot streak and briefly shared the top
spot but seeded it back to caruana after
faltering in round eight this set up a
spectacular final round with four
possible players capable of catching the
leader however it was all for naught as
Fabiano caruana made the necessary draw
to secure first place winning his first
superbed chess classic play players now
hope to hit the ground running as they
prepare for superbed rapid and Blitz
Poland where they'll face new
Challengers faster time controls and the
return of the ultimate wild card
[Music]
thank you
welcome chess fans to day one here in
Warsaw Poland for the beginning of the
Superbad rapid and Bliss an exciting
rapid and Blitz event part of the grand
Chester this is the second leg as as you
can see here in Warsaw Poland the chess
fever is definitely on in the whole city
behind me you can see this big sign
rapid and Blitz everybody is ready for
the chest to begin let's go to the
studio and start the ash
we welcome you to the second step on the
2023 grandchild store and our coverage
of Superbad Poland we come to your life
from the San Luis chess club
hello and welcome everyone thanks for
joining us again I'm International
Master Nassif and I'm here with
Grandmaster yasu sarawan
delighted to see you again how did you
enjoy the break you know it was great
but I really missed work so I'm happy to
be back that wasn't what I wanted to
hear Hello everybody and welcome back to
our coverage of the grand Chester things
sure feel like they're in full swing as
Juan Magnus Carlson joins our tour but
before we get into Warsaw and the roster
of Players let's just review what
happened in Bucharest and our lead
leaderboard in the grantchester all
right our congratulations again to our
champion Fabiano caruana for winning the
tournament and gaining 13 grandchild
store points uh several players as you
see a tied for second with 7.8 grand
Chester points all the way down to Young
remember dayak was a wild card so he
doesn't get Grand Chester points and
once again our congratulations
yes and Fabi is currently the the leader
with 13 Grand to store points absolutely
and now let's get to the roster players
for Warsaw let's take a look wow what a
rush
world number one returning Magnus
Carlson from Norway welcome back Magnus
uh Wesley south from United States
Netherlands number one anishikiri
Frenchman Maxima Shiela grav Poland's
number one young Christoph Duda and an
American player who replaced being lyron
in this event livon aronia and welcome
back Lavon lavon's played in so many of
these Grand Chester points it's sure
nice to see him in the field the three
Romanian players Richard rapid Bogdan
Daniel Diaz and kiril chevchenko and the
Local Hero Ryder slavoy tashek from
Poland wonderful and our former Nancy we
have a 10 player round robin and in the
rapid time control is 25 minutes with 10
second increment
and in Rapid games there's a
non-traditional scoring system two
points for a win 1.4 draw and zero for
loss in the blitz however there will be
a traditional scoring system with one
point for win half for draw and zero for
loss and the time control is five
minutes with two two second increments
and no draw offers throughout and our
schedule
right we have three days of rapid and
two days of Blitz and today we will have
the first three rounds of the rapid
wonderful and very fortunate to have in
studio bar version VAR good to see you
how did you enjoy your break my friend
good to see you guys I had a nice break
and just relaxing and but now I'm very
excited to be back to see the action in
this tournament we have some very very
exciting players playing in this
tournament and I'm looking forward to it
so first we have Levon aronian who
replaced Dingle Iran eleven is one of
the very top players in the world URS
rating 2761 representing us winner of
the 2018 St Louis rapid and Blitz
Champion tournament and also the seventh
time branches to participant and he is
very dangerous in this format then we
have former world champion Magnus
Carlson the number one player for more
than 10 years and he basically won every
event you can think of representing
Norway 2015 grantchester champion and 20
from 2023 to 20 to 2013 2023 World chess
champion
yeah and then we have um uh three wild
cards we had baghdan Daniel dick from
Romania and then now we have rather from
Poland and KIRO chefchenko from Romania
as well
and we're gonna go to Romania we're
gonna go to Poland to our friends
Anastasia and Christian
thanks for and welcome back chess fans
to Warsaw Poland for at the beginning of
the second leg of the 2023 Grand Chester
the Superbad rapid and Blitz the action
as you can tell from the title is
getting faster and more furious and I
have to say the energy here in the city
of Warsaw Poland is just incredible
Immaculate energy everybody is excited
to see the former world champion Magnus
Carlson uh here playing chess or not for
the first time in Poland but for the
first time in the grand Chester and
Anastasia actually you had a fun
experience yesterday at the openings
after the opening ceremony we had a
simul and we also had one Magnus Carlson
participating tell us about your game
with Magnus yes thank you Christian I
mean it was a really great experience
all players gave the simultaneous
exhibition to local chess fans and also
including some celebrities and
influencers and I was the one also who
could play and I was so happy you know
that even you know to have this chance
to play against all these Grand Masters
I experience what does it mean GCT dream
coming through so I couldn't even
imagine that at the end of the day I
will manage to win the game with 22
moves only and I won this game against
all Grandmasters of course they share
responsibility because few all of them
they did a few moves each of them and I
would like to say that there were 25
games in total and three games
Grandmasters lost recruiting my game and
three draws they also made so it was
such a heavy day for me I'm so happy to
be back to grantchester to Warsaw and so
I'm so happy to see Christian you and
also Nazi Yasser and Tovar well
Anastasia I don't have a wild card for
you for this tournament but I'll put in
a good word for the next ones guys we
are excited about the games to begin and
we'll give you the inside scoop about
what's happening in we're so cold thank
you Christian thank you Anastasia we're
gonna call her awesome Anastasia from
now on outstanding beating Magnus I
don't care simul or otherwise well done
um lady honors for us and tell us about
the first round pairings right today
we'll start with Rapport against
chefchenko wait hashek against Carlson
gotta be a marquee matchup welcome back
Magnus Wesley so against Daniel diach
Duda against Geary and MPL against
Iranian another Marquee matchup those
two games certainly have my attention
and these players are going to be
fighting and what are they going to be
fighting for right there's a handsome
price one for this tournament that we'll
take a look at in a minute exactly as we
see the players getting wandered right
the first place uh forty thousand
dollars second thirty thousand third
twenty five thousand all the way down to
10th uh place at seven thousand there
you see the GCT points so if you tie for
first you will be chopping up 12 points
for those who tie but if you win clear
first you'll be getting 13 Grand
[Music]
[Applause]
I love this stage on the red color
walking on red carpet really really it
looks looks fabulous doesn't it and the
white sneakers they're beautifully
offset matching it's beautiful there
the players are being introduced why a
stadium uh sold out every day I'm told
and they're playing in the museum and
the history
of polished Jews and again in Warsaw
Poland VAR uh how do you like playing to
a sold out Stadium
pretty nice it's a lot of fun a lot of
fun to have an audience so it looks
really beautiful guys the venue and
there is our always passionately dressed
Lavon aronium sporting a blue what would
you call it yeah blue pattern yeah sure
you get to pick favorites yes of course
we're going to choose the winner of the
event now what I'm thinking guys is
we're going to handicap ourselves Magnus
Carlson comes in as the number one rated
number one seed and we could all just
choose him and say we did our best but
I'm saying he's off limits we can't
choose him so we're gonna choose
everybody but Magnus please sounds fair
yeah do the honors I'm gonna choose
Wesley
[Music]
he's in great Champion shaping this
tournament he has won two tournaments
already in Germany and Kazakhstan
recently so I and he likes this format
so I'm gonna go with Levon wow I I
wanted I wanted Wesley too you complete
me through threw me off hmm shouldn't
have let me go first yeah okay I'm gonna
go a little bit wild even though he's
not a wild card
somehow he really was impressive he was
undefeated in Bucharest Anish giri
played some really really excellent
chess
I think he's on a peak and I'm gonna go
with a very surprising honest Gary don't
let me down on each I will come and get
you we will ask Christian and Anastasia
to weigh in as well but maybe also in in
a production team we got to get uh in
there too and get his picks
we just heard the Christian pick Magnus
but he doesn't even get the memo
very very very nice
um I'm looking at the Marquee matchups
and in that mvl versus Lavon tell me
what Lavon has been doing while uh the
grand Chester took place in Bucharest he
didn't play Lavon didn't play in
Bucharest but he played very very
successfully recently hasn't he yes he
won a very strong tournament in
Kazakhstan it was a rapid in blitz so so
he's doing really well this year Yasser
he won the tournament in Germany you
were there earlier this year so he's
playing really well this year
unfortunately it's the first year he is
not in a grantchester so he missed out
not only but and now we have the world's
former world champion Magnus I hope it's
about to say I don't know who his
hairstyle is but the firearm
Agnes Carlson fashionably late getting
wounded he looks like a man who retired
he looks like a man who fell out of bed
yeah here they were otherwise he is a
formidable formidable force in the Chess
World just yeah
and we'll also have a guest who will
make a ceremonial move today right yes I
am going to take a horrible that I'll go
with Adam
but his last name
uh is uh the CEO of the supermarket he
will be making the ceremony
[Applause]
I have those pieces on the stage are
those 3D printed the entire look real
it's true they
they are fun
[Applause]
as we see uh Magnus reflecting on
extraordinary careers he's getting ready
for grantchester rapid and Blitz which
as we know he has stated publicly
numerous times he sees it as the
ultimate source and this is Adam
getting getting in the shakes
of course he'll be making the move on
our key matchup
another
slot is going to say e2d4 what do you
know
they're starting
would you like to start your tournament
first round against Magnus Carlson
I do I mean as long as it's wide pieces
right for sure oh the Polish
D4 B5 I once played a match with Boris
baskey where he shocked me uh three
times by playing B5 the first two games
were a draw
I only got him in the uh third game and
here Bishop takes B5 Bishop takes E4
Knight F3 is considered incredibly
strong for white it's really uh I wasn't
aware of those theories oh yes I only
discovered it after my match with more
plastic but a big surprise uh tell us
about uh the Polish defense to one D4 of
R yeah I see I found your game from 1990
yesterday there you go yeah so that
right before you were born right yeah no
I was still I was born in 1990 but I
agree with you Bishop takes B5 Bishop
takes E4 Knight F3 should be a big
Advantage for for white there but uh
wellitashek wants to keep his Center so
let's take a look now uh Magnus just
played Knight F6 in this position whoops
uh so and um there are some games
actually where Tasha had a game like
this played in 2013. yes we have one
game that's already headed to a draw mvl
uh live on or actually there's some
repetition but I think mvl didn't repeat
the third time but we can take a look
that's also a very interesting opening
yes yes what a start yeah absolutely uh
let's let's go back for a second to the
magnus's game so how Knight F6 is played
now attacking the pawn on e4 right and
you cannot play the move E5 of course
how to attack the Knight because the
bishop is going to capture the pawn on
G2 and it's a big problem here you lose
your Rook so you need to you need to
find a way to defend this Pawn here
there are a few options here I see not
so many games in database here this
Knight F6 is actually uh more rare move
here there are more games after the move
E6 in this position for example but
after Knight F6 uh you can play the move
Queen E2 which is the main line I see 24
games played I like this move Knight F3
Queen E2 defending and then you want to
get the Knight on F3 and Castle just
maintaining the control of the center so
why tashek is still thinking
um you definitely don't want to play the
move F3 because that's just going to be
weakening the position another
alternative would be the move Knight D2
which he just played protect he did he
just played yeah you cannot play the
move Knight C3 because you have the move
before so that's why so so 92 is played
and
there are a few few ways Magnus can
respond here and he just played the move
C5
trying to put pressure in the center
here very very interesting opening
choice so far for sure but the
aggression that Magnus is showing right
out of the box is for me at least a
little bit stunning because
with black the whole idea is to equalize
and only then after equalizing do you go
into mode of attack but this is amazing
do you think he chose this because
called the Polish defense and he's
playing in Poland oftentimes the answer
is yes that the players are aware that
they that of their
location and things like that City so uh
for example in Latvia there was the
Latvian Gambit that was being played by
Edmar Madness against Michael Tall so
that's amazing but let's turn to that
game another Marquee matchup between MBL
and Lavon because those players played
very quickly a London and Lavon said
give me your Pawn it's like a sharp I
get a line for black yeah is this called
the poison pond in the London because
that's what it sure seems like to me
well there it goes Queen takes B2 Knight
jumps out obviously we're threatening a
fork to the king in The Rook picking up
the Rook also the queen could be left
high and dry so black has to be careful
that his Queen doesn't get trapped
Knight D5
defends the square C7 but simultaneously
attacks uh the bishop on F4 it would be
very useful to get rid of that Bishop as
well as the side set the threat of
Knight C7 and this is what you were
saying and Nasi that we could see again
a very early draw repetition mvl said no
no no I'm not finished with you yet uh
Knight F3 and we're up to date with the
players and Jump Right In VAR and tell
us what the theoretically recommended
moves are at this point uh only one game
played in only database yes sir yeah and
uh here
Lebon has a few options he can play the
move Knight A6 ish and that still will
allow white to repeat if he wants to
with Rook B1 Rook A1 so that's one
option another option he has is to take
on D4 so I I think you know he has to
probably choose between these two moves
um I assume it makes no sense for us to
go Knight C7 check and take a rook uh
after Knight takes F4 after Knight takes
F4 let's see here
uh yeah just e takes F4 would be nice
simple position and still the threat of
Knight C7 is very strong so I think it's
important to keep the Knight on D5 for
now just to control that C7 Square here
so the top moves are as I mentioned
Knight A6 in this position and C takes
D4
so there is a very interesting viation
after C takes D4 okay there is a move
Bishop D3 just trying to catch up on the
development because black is really
behind in development at this point
white doesn't care about the material so
much and now Queen B4 check
and now you give up another Pawn you're
going to be four pounds down now guys C3
wow D take C3 and you castle and but you
have such a big leading development that
despite being down four pawns you
actually have very strong compensation
here wow four pounds
I'm used to the Danish Gambit which I
was sacrificing two pawns as a
Scholastic player you know but four
pawns yeah but that is a huge yeah let's
take a look like this position it's it's
it's a very sharp now and you still need
this move Knight A6 looks like you
really need this move when the Knight is
zombie five to cover the C7 square and
uh here white can Retreat Bishop G3 and
then get ready to play the move E4 to
remove this knight from D5 black needs a
lot of moves to complete the
developmental Castle so this is one
interesting line uh and the question is
if uh you know level one will go for
this because it's very dangerous you
could be in a receiving end of like a
the game where you just you know lose
under 20 moves because you have no
development
receiving end of a brilliancy let's just
take a look around the stage uh we'll
jump in the game between Rapport and
Carol as this looks like a very
intriguing rosalimo G7 G6 takes takes D4
takes Queen takes and now you you want
to sidestep the move Knight F6 E5
so S7 F6
black has the two Bishops big Center
a little bit awkward though uh
development Queen A4 uh I presume to
sidestep e5s d5s as well you keep a
little pressure on the C6 pawn bishop G7
C4 setting up a maroxy mine kind of uh
situation Queen B6 castles Knight H6 and
what is the state of uh the theory in
this one a VAR this looks way off the
Beaten Track for me
I see one game in my database very high
profile game and VL was playing with
white against rajabov
and this is from 2019. if we go back a
few moves the move Queen A4 is actually
very rare move in this position so in
this position instead of Queen A4 most
most people play the national move
Castle or the move C4 so Queen A4 it has
been played few times but only a few
times so after Queen A4 and I want to
get to the current position here and
you know white has nice control of the
center and looks like a little bit
easier to play but the advantage for
black is that he has the pair of the
Bishops here so here white can continue
with the move Knight C3 which is a very
natural move and then when you put a
knight on H6 in this position almost
always you put it back here on F7 to
control the E5 and D6 squares and here
white can try to go for this before idea
the point is to try to put a Pawn on C5
and move the queen from B6 so and then
we can enter some very interesting
variations after F5 C5 now Queen has to
retreat say queen A6 Queen B3 and
engines are showing a slight advantage
in this position for white which is not
surprising because you have a better
lead in development and black king is
still in the middle of the board as well
thank you VAR just
being told that in this very very sharp
Gambit game between MBL and Lavon that
darush doesn't like this move Knight C6
that mvl actually is move orders kind of
through
um Lavon off of track a bit Knight C6
was not on the computer's top moves why
is that VAR this move actually will
allow the move C4 I think the movie C4
is critical in this position to try to
have an advantage because you need to
remove that knight from D5 so let's take
a look after the move C4
so black has a few options you can take
on F4 or can play the move Knight CB4
let's start out with Knight CB4 because
now you have a very dangerous threat of
Knight C2 check but this move is
actually losing now because after the
move Rook B1 you're attacking the queen
and if you play the move Knight C2 check
white can simply play King D2 and then
you have to move your queen and then
Queen takes it to you're losing a piece
so that's why Knight C2 doesn't work and
if you play the move for Queen A2 which
is the only Square to go to here and
white can just simply Play Bishop D3
just developing the bishop controlling
the C2 square and getting ready to
Castle now and the Knight C7 threat is
still remaining and it's going to be a
big problem for black here this is
actually a completely winning position
now for white
completely winning yeah it's like almost
plus four here if the night goes to B4
if the Knight takes yeah let's take a
look at Knight x74 I think that's more
critical here 964 makes more sense
because you're actually eliminating the
bishop but this is also not as good
because a very important move here in
between move Rook B1 attacking the queen
and now Queen has to go to a to only
move and here we don't capture we don't
have to capture on C7 we can simply go
for this move Knight C7 check King goes
on d8 and Knight takes A8 and white is
up exchange the Knight is still hanging
on F4 and if you Retreat Knight G6
white can actually play the move Knight
G5 now now attacking on F7 so again this
is a this is a big advantage
that Knight G5 is a very unpleasant one
and there we see Lavon doing his little
straw uh shaking off cobwebs of uh his
opening now I've noticed that he likes
to walk during the game yes but even
during rapid and Blitz he still walks a
lot which you think hey you know like
okay how do you pace yourself
at the American Cup when he was playing
uh Blitz against I think Wesley or
Fabian he was yeah taking his time
walking around I wish I could do that I
know I'm too nervous I want to sit at
the board let's just again sorry we're
not going through all of the positions
but let's just jump back uh to the game
of Magnus for a second rather sloth just
played the move D for D5 I mean he's
made a a great effort at keeping his uh
Center intact and normally speaking if
you were white here you might want to
stop you know the move night before you
go A3 you go B3 you go Bishop B2 petite
little moves you you you stay behind
your classical Central Pawn Duo no yeah
sorry if it wasn't a Magnus playing this
with black I would think white is just
winning yeah look at this position that
we have on the board well okay let's go
for it uh you you you attack me actually
we have few moves on the board yeah
well I I kind of thought it was going to
go that way I was about to play night
before Bishop back and then take but
take E5 I think that's
um a crucial
follow-up if you will and okay uh I'm a
pawn Grabber Magnus played the move
Knight H5 uh
and just he's essentially saying do your
worst and what is the worst what's going
to happen
um I think white needs to move the
knight from D2 so okay Bishop right
maybe Knight B3 just so I have an id4
option as well okay so giving yourself
this Square I didn't know if you were
going to come back but I do see yeah I
mean like okay I got a visual on that
incoming so uh G7 G6 no Bishop H6 right
to get my I was going to give my knight
a square but you're not going to allow
me an easy life now oh
weird is this I'm starting to look
at positions where you've played G4 and
G takes H5
and your king is a little exposed so the
question is is
yeah I was going to say if I block the
diagonal then
yeah you'll just be up a piece uh
uh I don't know I don't think it's gonna
work yeah I don't I I I'm not impressed
by my own clever designs Bishop f8 just
to give myself again I think we have
this moves on the board by the way we do
have night before we have G6 on the
board
once per broadcast I really like to get
this in these guys are good yeah well
they're pretty good
and standing room only in the aisles as
we see if you don't get here early you
don't get a seat and I know that feeling
I I was in the Soviet Union where you
know it was more crowded than a bus in
Kiev is what uh
alexovich said to me uh jump in uh VAR
I'm not feeling it for Magnus in fact
I'm looking at this position
and
Nasi was bringing the Heat and it feels
very uncomfortable absolutely yeah 9b3
is a great move actually opening up the
diagonal for the bishop we have Bishop
H6 on the board as well yes and it's a
very big Advantage here for white Air
and I will show you how can uh you know
with Asha continue and I think Magnus is
really taking a big big risk in this
game here so in this position now Bishop
H6 played and the threat is G4 and after
which your knight will be trapped so you
can play you have two options you have
to play Bishop which is the best move or
Rook G8 which is going to be very ugly
move just the idea because you can't go
back Rook G8 he went with ugly yeah so
this is really bad I mean this whole
position here here white actually can
just do many different things here but
for example you can bring your Bishop
back only three here
and now you're trading the move Knight
C5 so if you play let's say 97 you need
to bring this Knight into the game
because it's doing absolutely nothing on
H5 then you play the move Knight C5
attacking the bishop and Bishop takes C5
the bishop C5 now you have a very strong
dark Square Bishop yes your knight will
land only six but now this bishop is
just gonna be a monster there so this is
a very very big Advantage for white in
this position if you don't want to give
up your dark Square Bishop after the
move Knight C5 you can play something
like Queen B8 so if I capture you take
back with the queen but here white
doesn't have to take immediately can
play the move Bishop C2 now putting
pressure on D5 at some point Bishop can
go on B3 as well again black king is
stuck in the middle of the board and
doesn't look like you're going to be
able to Castle anywhere so there's a big
big danger here for Magnus in this game
uh not for nothing but I don't find
Bishop E3 uh so intuitive I would have
thought something like Rook C1
similarly going for Knight C5 only as
you were pointing out reasons why Bishop
E3 Bishop takes C5 uh do I suddenly find
it attractive but Bishop you went Bishop
H6 and now your very next turn playing
Bishop E3 not easy to do Rook C1 is also
a great move yeah sir yeah just you can
actually just play Rook C1 here as well
and still have like a very big Advantage
very big Advantage let's just jump to
the game of mvl and Lavon because that
whoa and can I ask you to go back just
onto move 11 when Queen C1 was played
okay we just saw the move Knight C6 we
were expecting C4 and it said King
Bishop C4 Knight C3 queensy Quick Check
and just look at this position in the C
file
it's like it's completely full on move
12 oh 11. I've I don't think I've ever
seen this before have you ever gotten on
the elevator it says 1200 kilos at
maximum I mean that's what the CFL feels
like like a full elevator nobody else
can get on uh Bishop C4 looked pretty
good and this position well we have to
trade Queens because Knight The Rook is
hanging the queen is hanging so takes
tags
E5
this is so hard to evaluate
well in Iraq in a correspondence scheme
I might have trouble in a rapid gamer
wow okay e five good stuff but you have
to do it wait chess players we're going
to recognize in patterns and that's how
we evaluate positions sure but no one
has seen eight pieces on one file like
this is very hard for me to figure out
what's going on which pieces are hanging
which pieces are safe and which pieces
are important uh there was a moment uh
there okay and by the way before we get
too deep
wow these players know each other well
15 wins in Rapid versus three losses mvl
has a huge yeah it's pretty good in
Rapid and I would have never guessed
that because they have met some often in
these in these uh knockout tournaments
these 128 player knockout the World Cup
tournaments and I thought that Lavon
actually got the better of mvl in those
events so anyway here there was this one
line a moment ago where VAR was telling
us about takes takes and Knight G5 was a
very very awkward move for black to me
because you want to take this Pawn in
this particular position D5 and you were
just saying a moment ago I don't know
how to evaluate uh
because
because I thought you used to sing both
nights at the the quarter uh bar you
gotta jump in and bail us out on this
one I have no idea what's going on yeah
absolutely crazy and that's the main
line guys that's the main line that's
the main line actually and I went a
little bit deeper here I will show you
but it looks like Leon is doing great uh
at the end of this line here let me show
you so in the current position after the
move E5 mvl has to take Knight a that's
the best move here everything else is
going to be much worse for him so after
night eight we take the bishop now
Knight G5 again only move because this
Knight is going to get trapped and you
will just simply lose the game if you
don't play the move Knight G5 so Knight
G5 D5 okay attacking the bishop Knight
F7
King E8 now the Knight is hanging so it
will take and it's very unusual you went
both you took both Rooks on it and h8
and you last year both Bishops one on F4
and now one on C4 at least we see a
symmetry of what's Happening here so now
Knight C7 you need to get the Knight
back into the game and uh because this
Knight is trapped right now and if you
allow black to play Bishop D6 this other
night you're gonna get trapped so you
need this move and now King D7 comes in
Knight is still trapped on C7 and only
way to escape is try to push this move
D5 to try to get that E64 for the Knight
to go to but in this case black would
just take
take Zone C6 and now you play King C6
and here we have a very strong Knight on
C3 a lot of Pawns here on the queen side
here black white does have the extra
material here but uh evaluation is
actually close to vehicle but very hard
to understand what's going on so etax F4
is the best move
and now white can a block can play the
move Bishop E6 just to control the F7
Square so the Knight cannot come out and
if F5 is played you don't want to take
this Pawn because the Knight will come
back on a Sim you play the move Bishop
D5 so you centralize the bishop you're
still controlling the F7 square and at
some point you're gonna start pushing
the sponsor so complicated position but
I think it's a little bit easier to play
for black because your plan is very
direct just Advance your pawns on a
queen side here but the position still
around equal at this point remarkable
materially I think black is doing great
but it's a very very strange position I
have another game I was just looking at
and that was between Duda and Anish Gary
and right up until here it's been a
Kings Indian slash benoni with Bishop D3
and F3 and I always had this theory that
I carried with me that benoni is bad the
benoni is a bad defense for black when
all the pieces are on the board if black
early in the game can trade a single
piece of minor pieces whether it be
Knights or Bishops much of the space
disadvantage goes away so uh in this
particular game Anish has managed to
trade off a knight for a bishop so I
think he's doing really pretty decently
right about this point as black and I
would have expected some kind of a
benoni-like move of A6 and possibly even
F5 recognizing the potential of a good
Square B5 was a more Bangkok style yeah
but also a kind of an overreach like why
do you need it so well do this because
it's rapid because it's rapid uh you can
take more risks there we go Knight takes
B5 and from Judas point of view you've
got to prove something I'm going to play
Knight C4 and I'm going to try to
capture this Pawn on D6 now of course
you can go Bishop B5 A4 and maybe even
on a good day pardon me on a good day
even win this Pawn but you've done me
such a service of playing B5 and giving
me the C4 square that I'm really
confused and if you play Rook B pardon
me if you play Rook B8 and I just
Retreat can Anish just go G4 and play
you on the king side let's try let's see
put pressure
uh it it does feel a little bit
illogical pretty sure maybe well no
you're going to go B5 on one hand and G4
where are you playing uh you want to
beat me on both sides of the board okay
um
well be if I was a distraction so
exactly far away now
uh I'm not exactly sure what I'm afraid
of if you're are you going to take or
you're going to go check or
um I'm not exactly sure what I should be
afraid of so so go ahead and let's say
do your worst like uh beat me all right
let's follow up with F5 okay and now I
want to get rid of this Knight somehow
let's get rid of that night
let's take on e4
okay now I pause because
before I didn't think I was going to
have much of a choice like I was going
to play Knight takes E4 all the time
here I'm kind of considering Rook takes
E4
just because I have to the temple
yeah okay I'll I'll fall for it
um
I do Bishop F5 or
I'll take one I don't care about that
but here also I feel like even if worse
comes to worse and I lose an exchange I
get something so uh VAR uh help clear
the cobwebs a bit B5 was that an
overreach by Anish or he has a a very
specific follow-up in mind
um if it is a move that it's okay to
play but it wasn't necessary he could
have simply played the move B6 in that
position yeah and have that same plan
Bishop Basics coming up and block is
actually slightly better in this
position exactly also he could have just
played the move F5 there instant of the
move B6 again black is slightly better
because it looks really nice you get you
have two Bishops excellent Knight on F4
it's a dream dream benoni slash Kings
Indian type of position so the move B5
is uh but he does have a compensation
here and we see a couple of moves played
after the move Knight B5 so 95 Rook B8
plate now you get the open file that's
the the main idea why he played this
move and now A6 is played because A4 and
now A6 now removing removing the Knight
and here you have to go back on C3 this
is the only move Knight A7 you're going
to lose some V2 so only move will be
Knight C3 and here you you just gain it
you just gain an open a file for your
rook and here you have to continue with
the move F5 you really need this move to
try to put some pressure in the center
and to bring the bishop into the game
it's a complicated position evaluation
is equal right now but again
two Bishops and open B file I find this
easier to play with the black pieces a
couple of more moves we can look at it
Rook A1 and then F takes E4 and if you
take with the Knight either of the
knights Bishop F5 will come in so good
compensation for our Niche but again the
pawn sacrifice wasn't uh completely
necessary exactly let's just turn back
to our game of the world's number one
player uh radislav versus Magnus when we
left it we saw Bishop H6 Rook G8 we call
Black's position ugly which it is but
one follow-up is you want to play for
the C5 Knight C5 uh move try to force
black to give up the bishop the engines
preference for that is to pre to start
with Bishop E3 which uh White did and
then Queen C7 not I just found Bishop
takes C5 too ugly yeah I just thought
that this position I mean it's it's like
a meeting I should not have played this
opening yeah I mean that Bishop on D6
just makes such a powerful impression
and Magnus didn't want anything to do
with that he played Queen C7 uh
suggesting
yeah I'm ready to exit and maybe also
play 96. Rook C1 96 takes tags
Bishop
interesting because I somehow I had it
in my mind the bishop was coming to B1
Bishop to F1 by white Bishop to D4
rookie two
Knight E7
well he had to make room to defeat he
won a pawn as ugly as it is at least
he's clinging to something you know like
a life raft you know he's he's got to
maintain something for his ugly position
and
we
we have Rook double on C2
I I mean optically it feels like White's
got just about everything after all
where is Black going to put his King how
good or bad do you think this is nice
and quiet's winning just winning it's
just so strong yeah I mean control of
the open file
um but what Magnus has going in his
favor is that he's Magnus Carlson well
he's got the he's got the business
squares on the C file cover it up so
yeah so if I go like Knight F5
hoping to get in some Bishops of
opposite color if I ever get rid of the
dark Square Bishop my king could
castle by hand
look at the current position I loved
what white did he put the bishop on F6
let's see what he did I am just going to
re-re refresh my board everybody don't
be mad
um Rook C2 Knight of hit he did go
Knight to five
and he said he said your best piece is
the night on E6 I'm willing to let you
trade it off but you have to give me
your night on E6 Magna set Bishop back
Bishop F6 sorry to interrupt you you
like what you're saying because if
Magnus exchanges the bishop now the
point goes to F6 yeah and black king can
never hide on G7 that's what I was about
to say I I like the idea
split in Black's position in half
exactly uh here I can understand why the
bishop could easily go to G2 and
pressure D5 Bishop F6 so you're right
I'm not going to take on but that leaves
me Knight F to G7 I think he's headed to
H5
trying to
somehow get rid of that Bishop wow uh uh
the world well world's number one is
taking an insane amount of Liberties in
this game uh and I'm sensing serious
upset of our tell me you uh your your
your thoughts and feelings absolutely
agree with you I think voitashek is
playing a great game and Magnus is just
really really gambling in this game here
and here uh the whiteashek has an
incredible move here he just needs to
calculate a little bit and find it that
movie is Knight G5 here
Knight G5 yes sacrificing a piece but
the idea is every time you capture this
night from with your knight only six you
can allow me to smooth Rook C7 okay and
that's going to be a big problem here I
will show you the lines now guys so
Knight G5 and first it seems like wait a
minute it looks like just blundering a
piece but once you take it Rook C7 comes
in attacking the queen and the next
thing is D5 Pawn is gonna fall here so
if you play the move Queen B8 I simply
play Queen takes D5 and now D7 is
hanging and you don't have a good way to
protect this and if you go Queen d8 then
it's a very nice finish Queen takes A8
group six eight Rook CA check you take
and then you get a back crank Checkmate
on d8 here once again King is stuck in
the middle of the board here but he did
not play that move Knight G5 is kind of
a tough move to find so you play the
move Queen D3 and this is actually
losing some of his Advantage because the
point of this move Knight G7 is to play
the move Knight H5 now and try to force
this bishop to exchange and that way
King can take only seven and finally
black can connect his Rooks here and
that's what his Magnus trying to achieve
in this position so I think he will play
this move Knight H5 now and there is no
way for you to protect F6 anymore so I
feel like now he's he's coming back into
the game here so white is still better
after Bishop E7 King E7 but at least the
king is fine and the Rooks are going to
be connected still an advantage for
white not as much
was quite surprising for me especially I
thought G3 and Bishop G2 was on
White's agenda there so the move Queen
D3 and Bishop takes and Max instead of
going Knight H5 well Magnus is trying to
say uh I think the pawn on F6 is weak as
we just see this move Knight H5 let me
just put the only way to defend now is
crazy three right
[Music]
yes but hmm that's kind of a
it feels awkward the thing is if you
play B4 do I have Quincy eight I think I
do
there is a knight d8 business
then you gotta check on the this is
something yeah this is a very funny
check uh before yeah I will have to take
it six Rook takes and if Knight d8 that
will definitely lead to a Checkmate
after rookie one that is cute
yeah that pawn on F6 is
and by the way uh time wise
checks down to 10 minutes and Magnus
still has 14 minutes
um not in time trouble yet but just in
the in that line that we were looking at
if I returned the queen and Nasi uh the
the the the the pawn on F6 is vulnerable
well true but trying to I can pick it
off Queen side pawns maybe like I can
win A6 and probably B4 as well and
something of this nature although I mean
this doesn't feel like completely clean
I mean you know
uh
is on the board on the board so they're
up to this moment and now this is the
key mode key moment that there is D5 D4
maybe that's better considerable as a
consideration there is B4 the whole idea
is you can't live with this Bond on F6
gotta get rid of it uh sorry we're just
gonna uh I look along with Bruce Harper
very dear friend of mine we wrote a book
called King walks whenever I see the
king going on a voluntary March I just
have to I just have to look and so did
not take on A8 he did not take on A8 he
took on E5 and
essentially
allowed this position where first of All
Black's King is remarkably safe I mean I
mean you can't even check the check the
case at night on Sir threes it's so good
secondly
um
materially speaking I'm sorry I'm still
okay I'm not sure either I've got two
pieces for a rook right yes or
so no uh why it is an exchange app but
black has two pawns for it because the
Knight is not yet captured but look at
those pawns I mean this queen side
majority is going to be just enormous my
first thought is that this is all going
spectacularly well for Lavon
like he can play
C4 Bishop A3 win back as exchanged very
nicely he started with Bishop takes H7
here maybe I can get my night out the
training look at you going grabbing
pumps I thought the same though I maybe
the difference is Lavon is looking to
take on D4 and play Bishop B4 I think I
need to get my night out right now
Knight G6 Bishop to be yeah this is
starting to look scary right yeah
and there you go I mean it's not greed
it's really trying to save the night oh
I can't Castle because of 92. Castle's
92 is definitely uh
a check you didn't want to see that is
right
and livon did go C4
C4 so actually he could have done it a
different move order I thought C4 was
the most foreseen moment ago but Bishop
E6 Bishop takes H7 instead of capturing
on D4 which I was doing with for the
tempo C4
clear
excuse me clear ideas of Bishop A3 and
Bishop B4
really I don't like uh mvl's position if
he
if this is good for mvl I'm I'm I'm
stunned I mean I think he he's got to
start thinking about F3 King F2 and
bailing out because his game's not good
yeah White's trying to survive I think I
think so too again let me just check in
because radislav
yeah he is really
um okay Queen C3 stop for a little bit
here Rook d8
so no b4s no d4s
A3 just sidestepping B4 for the time
being and asking
Magnus to do something
I will I just want to say that the
immediate D4 it takes it doesn't allow
you to capture because Knight takes will
be winning for white so D5 D4 doesn't
offer much of a solid instead of A3 I
really liked Rook E1
I like because I feel like we don't need
to have three pieces on C file anymore
exactly
uh you know I like rookie one uh rookie
wanted my again I just to Echo your
words I you don't need to hear it yeah
yeah Queen E5 Queen E5 and again I'm
kind of sorry to pound the table here
but I really like G3 and Bishop G2 as
well A3 was played and Magnus is time
effector again uh not yet Magnus Magnus
is five minutes up he has 12 minutes
while voitashek has seven
okay well you start to start to feel it
just a little bit uh sorry we did not
look at the Wesley so game apologies to
our Wesley fans of which I include
myself we'll do it very quickly it came
from a
um piano only classical opening we have
today so far so far
why
okay a little bit better
but I must say that I always find that
these these positions that very much
resemble rui Lopez as a very hard to
um
to determine who is an advantage so
we've just seen takes and I imagine
black will recapture with the pawn
attacking the pawn on e4 uh as wife yeah
as white about equal right yeah that's
my feeling too it's white I would want
to return the favor as soon as possible
and play Knight to C4 by the way Anish
Gary let me just quickly check when we
left it
um
oh The Rook B2
kind of
sacrifice or exchange happened
oh that's nasty a royal Fork go ahead
take my Bishop make my day it will cost
you your queen so the queen went to A2
and now we have opposite color Bishops
right but black one Bacchus Pawn a
petite combination
and we're up to date
here
are white uh just because the black
Square Bishop is missing from G7 I feel
like black king is slightly more
vulnerable absolutely
but now having said that you know
black is the one after all with the
passer that's the advantage of the
benoni that you get a queen side again
I'm gonna jump back to our game of uh
well the round at the moment uh Magnus
Carlson just played the move Queen B8
probably headed to F4 I yeah but I think
finally G3 G3 will somebody please uh I
think she will play it now reach across
the board my voice is really provoking
it now right
exactly except to G3 do you think Magnus
will play Queen D6
yeah
what else are you what else can you do
right
there we go G3 thank you and if we do
see Queen D6 I liked what you said a
moment ago let me play rookie one just
to uh so earlier when I was playing
rookie one if black moved the king to f8
I had Queen before check which was
unpleasant but now with the queen on D6
moving the king to f8 makes a lot more
sense is in this case you do have D4 on
your agenda yes
and I agree I think Queen 96
in his position yeah fighting out of it
uh Richard Rapport by the way uh and
again apologies uh we left it at Queen
A4
sometimes in these Rapids the games get
lost as the excitement uh moves
elsewhere uh Queen A4 Queen B6 now
Richie said hey I can see what mvl did I
can sacrifice my B-2 Pawn poison Pawn
you can't take it yes I can said Carol
do your worst Queen B7 okay so white won
a number of Tempe
to achieve precisely what well he got
his Pawn back
that was good like Richard's position
especially the current one yes
C5 that looks great
I'm just I I'm thinking I have to play
D5 so I'm just trying to catch up with
the players uh are you going to kill me
with Knight D4 Knight F D4 probably yeah
either one and I I don't know if I
should
I feel like I'm on the back foot as
black
but is there a knockout though Knight
takes C6 and the other Knight to D4 yeah
absolutely
I feel like I'm in a game show like you
know like like you know somebody was
gonna whack maybe immediately C6
threatening Rook B7 and Knight B5 I mean
this is yeah complete domination on the
queen side
no argument from me uh yeah this looks
like uh Carol's on the back foot for
sure let's just jump to Magnus for a
moment and after this move G3 VAR we've
been looking at Queen D6 and king f8 and
the combination of Queen D6 first we
think Magnus is fighting his way back
yeah he's actually uh you know he's
still much worse but not as much earlier
with Ashok had a great opportunity I
will show you he had a huge Advantage if
they found this move Queen E5 here
instead of the move A3 so we if we just
go back to this position after the move
Rook date he had this move Queen E5 it's
very strong nowadays move because you're
also getting ready to play Rook C7 here
and if you play the move D6 then you
simply go Queen to E3 and now Rook C7
again is going to be very very strong if
you let's say capture on F6 now Rook C7
attacking the queen queen B8 and once
again we see this move from Knight G5
coming in again King is stuck in the
middle of the board here and this is
just simply winning here this A3 move
it's it's it's it's a nice move you're
preventing the move before because the
idea was trying to deflect the queen
from here and try to pick up the pawn F6
but now black is going to bring the
queen into the game with Queen B8 and
queen D6 I think coming up so after G3
here Queen D6 white is still better but
uh you know there are some chances to
pick up this Pawn at some point and then
King will be safe here so with the time
Advantage as well I think Magnus has
some chances now to get back into the
game and talking about time actually
Magnus caught up with voytastic they
both have right yes six minutes and 40
seconds or something like that so I
think everything will be decided in this
blitz now wow and uh Magnus came up with
a move
we certainly were were not considering
G6 G5 that's where that uh I think this
is in five minutes uh went I mean okay
obviously his idea is pretty
straightforward guys he's so invited
Knight D4 isn't it 94 Knight F5
sure does look good uh yeah
94. now my Bishop's open I can go to G2
or H3 or even on the other side if
needed E2 or D3 you know yeah well let's
let's try to imagine that black black
follows up with his idea of rook and he
he's rounding up the pawn okay he's just
asking you if I take the pawn
so that Rook is defended by the Knight I
thought I could maybe
somehow maybe First bishop H3 and then
Bishop G4 this
should be Bishop you
I'm I don't think you're gonna make it
well I'm gonna kind of try I'm trying to
roll with the punches here and uh King
athay we did indeed see after the move
G5
Rook E1 uh
94. what has it has an attraction but
okay E1 also looks very good and jump in
VAR uh
it feels like the game is going to be
decided in extreme movies
oh by the way uh I think we have a
repetition going on between mvl
and uh but let's throw it to Bucharest
and get the pardon me Bucharest
Christian and in Warsaw view from Warsaw
uh VAR infected me just a just a quick
update on that game between voitashek
and Magnus Magnus opening up with the
Polish opening this is something that
he's done before as well in uh actually
much more serious encounters and uh one
at the world championship match against
Sergey kariakin in 2016. after uh Donald
Trump just got elected he played the
trampolsky in game one and that was a
last minute decision we just got that
information from one of his seconds in
that match uh uh Gustafson who is here
with Anish giri so quite an interesting
outcome in that one he did pile on the
pressure with the white pieces in that
particular game right now it seems like
he is getting punished for his uh
courageous decision to open up with the
Polish back to you guys thank you
Christian and we did have a repetition
in a very uh roller coaster ride of a
game between mvl and Yvonne I thought
that Levon really had an advantage
coming out of this strange
London system as the players themselves
are a bit confused uh sorting the
details out but but let them sort the
details out bar I'm going to jump it
over to you with the game of Magnus
because I'm thinking in the next few
moves this game is going to be decided
one way or another
I think so Magnus is in big trouble I
didn't like this move G5 at all it
really weakens the position
yeah and now he played the move G5 G4
actually now he's trying to remove the
knight from F3 uh and here this is just
gonna Force the Knight to go to a good
Square on D4 you actually can play
Knight H4 here as well if you want to
but I like this move 94 just more
centralizing you cannot take on F6
because I can simply take only six and
then capture the Knight on F6 so that
loses a piece that's so I think he's
trying to play this move Rook G6 and try
to finally get rid of the Knight on uh
the pawn on F6 but now we have the move
Bishop D3 coming in right attacking The
Rook Rook takes F6 and now the move
Knight F5 and again Knight is very bad
on H5 Now The Rook is vulnerable King
stuck in the middle of the board so
really really difficult position here
um there the best move here is to play
before to sacrifice a pawn and after a
takes before try to play this move King
f8 I think I was just gonna say so if
black doesn't play B4 White's just going
to play Queen B4 and take on G4 and game
soccer right exactly if you play uh King
f8 definitely four check picking up on
G4 that will be game over immediately
the desirable queen king fa King G8
running for the king side actually ends
up losing a pawn with a check and you're
getting nothing for it therefore B4 but
also uh the more I look at it and I like
centralized Knights the reason why I I
find my eye drawn to Knight H4 is it
kind of crosses up your plan yeah
there's no more Rook G6 Rook takes F6 my
Knight's still coming to F5 I don't lose
that option but I do deny Rook G6 so I
find myself attracted to Knight H4 maybe
a black can play Rook G5
G5 uh but at least in this particular
case you're not uh gobbling my F6 uh
Pawn right away and I do always thanks
to the pin I was like thank you you're
not giving me your your Pawn for free
that that would be delish
yeah I don't know I I can't find the
good moves for black it's not easy it's
not easy it's uh again uh sorry to Bo
sorry to ask but it's time
so slowly they aren't so why Tasha's
down to three and a half minutes and he
played the centralizing move Knight to
D4
is inviting Rook G6 in that whole idea
before
if you were to if the engine was to give
this an estimation of who stands better
what's the score it's plus four for
white yes no way
I wouldn't have guessed it was that high
yeah
plus two plus four that's a whole piece
why is it so bad Rook G6 what we looked
at yes Bishop D3 we looked at Rook takes
F6 we looked at Knight F5 we looked at
B4 a b king F eight we more or less
stopped here and this is the plus four
yes after a b king f8 and actually white
plays the move B5 here just to give up
that pawn to get that square on B4 for
the queen
nice
nice okay we're just going to take a
pause and we're going to jump over to
Richie reports game against Carol
because he's about to win yeah we think
the Rook just went dominating Square
Rook C7 Queen D5 on the board now
queenies 27 Queen E5 and
96 I guess absolutely yeah 25 and 96 and
black cannot protect the seventh rank
it's gonna lose a piece or get
checkmated here so
and he's he's just played Queen E7 we're
expecting 96.
wow great start
Richie nobody picked Richie Queen check
King H2 Bishop to E5 check but that's
just oh excuse me no we can
we can go Bishop C1 that's easier that's
much easier because King H2 Bishop E5
check and takes is still a little bit
tricky right I've got G7 covered by the
queen but Bishop C1
uh yep game over
and and we do have a handshake our
congratulations to Ricky Richie's shame
on you guys nobody picked Richie he was
undefeated in Bucharest he No Love No
Love
and Magnus we do have Knight D4 Rook G56
Rook G5
sometimes it's very difficult to
pinpoint where Magnus is going I mean he
makes this obvious suggestion that he's
going to go take the pawn and then he
goes Rook G5 I think he's just trying to
get a rattles live in serious time
trouble so he can have chances
two minutes now okay and Magnus has
three minutes and 42 seconds so it's
really intriguing almost twice as much
time now right we we've been talking
about the power of that square F5 and
the fact that the Knight was was
standing so beautifully there with the
move Bishop D3 and the Knight coming to
F5 Magnus might be preparing an exchange
sacrifice simply he's he's looking to
play Knight takes F6 and when Knight
does land on F5 he could sacrifice
exchange again a minute 40 seconds I
tell you when you're at the board you
think your clock is ticking faster than
it is yeah for sure and sometimes uh you
think you only been thinking for two
seconds and look at the clock and two
minutes is gone yeah right like what
happened
so he really needs to four Jump Right In
we just had to move Rook G5
your engine is saying plus four where
we're confused we don't know why it's
such a high valuation for white so help
us out plus five now yes sir plus five
but it's not easy to play it's like
there's still a lot of moves that you
have to find and uh you know let me show
you for example this one variation here
after Rook G5 so Bishop D3 needs to be
played okay is this a logical move to
play
uh so now after Bishop D3 yep uh let's
say if you play the move King f8 which
is very large this is what he's gonna
play the move King f8 and now uh you
have to play Knight takes E6 oh that's
hard and D takes E6 and then Bishop
takes H7 and this is where you retain a
big Advantage because now threatening to
play Queen B4 or queen C5 check and uh
at the end there is a move Queen D6
because black is just one move away so
just to pick up that pawn on F6 then
he's gonna be very happy but after Queen
D6 there is the move Queen E3 attack in
the rook and you're winning Exchange in
this variation finding such precise
moves it's not easy seconds but at least
from from White's point of view he
started well Bishop D3 he's eyeballing
H7 just as you suggested take the pawn
on H7 stop the king from getting to the
king side but I find that move Knight
takes E6 counter-intuitive
E3 as well that is that is really tough
so King f8
Knight takes E6 takes an E6 Bishop takes
H7 Queen D6 Queen E3 give me The Rook
give me the square H6
and that's why
it's plus five yes but well it only has
50 seconds on the clock so 50 seconds
that three minutes melted
yep and none of this moves that fire was
showing are intuitive moves well Bishop
D3 I can get behind that one now the
question for black is if King f8 and
King G8 is a dead end
um you start looking uh for Alternatives
uh VAR alternatives for beside King f8
B4 is another alternative here again
it's very important in a lot of these
lines to blockade that diagonal okay so
a B for a b yeah and here you can play
the move Rook E5 just to complicate the
matters why tashek has only 50 seconds
so still a lot of pieces on the board
and you still have to navigate through
some of the complications here exactly
file like for example here the best
movie is Rook CC1 Rook ccc1
not intuitive
what group C to E2 seems so much yeah
let's say you play Rook C to E2 you you
still have an advantage but now it
dropped a little bit I can take only two
and then after Rook takes it two I can
play the move Rooks by the way we did
have uh after the move Bishop D3 Magnus
did not play B4 he played Rook E5 excuse
me I'm just going to refresh my board
and white immediately responded with
Knight F5 so Bishop D3 rookie 5 Knight
F5 Rook takes E1 check Queen takes E1 on
the board Knight takes F6
Magnus got rid of this Pawn that was
clutching at his throat Knight takes F6
and VAR jump in has the assessment
changed greatly Queen B4 yeah that's a
great move now threatening Checkmate on
E7 and check made in one is forcing him
to move D6 after D6 after D6 you play
The Little Queen C3 now oh you don't
play Rook C6
no just Queen D6 on the board what's
wrong with it Rook C6 is also very
strong okay because I thought that was
the follow-up to to to Queen before you
won it but you say queen take Queen to
C3 is even stronger yeah they're both
very strong actually Queen C3 is
attacking the Knight on F6 and two great
moves for for for white but 30 seconds
yes Radisson is so close to beating
Magnus Carlson he's got two great moves
and he's got to choose one 25 seconds on
the clock he's got to choose one I can't
imagine how
stressed and excited he is right now I
could tell you your heart is racing you
feel like oh you play three great move
wow okay VAR jump in Queen C3 that's
that really puts a testament I play D4
maybe just two otherwise Queens go into
age eight right yes Queen can go on a
tree
teleporting to age eight so you can play
D4 and then Knight takes D4
yeah and uh play B4 is another idea just
to sacrifice a pound to the black's King
looks awfully vulnerable after D4 Knight
takes D4 I don't see what how D5 D4
really helped yeah I'm just getting
nervous here look at magnus's clock
catching up down to 45 seconds
whoa and do they get increment after
move 60
no it's just they're they're playing on
there well I think that's for the blitz
yeah okay I think they're just playing
or playing on their increment Queen C3
Knight D7 wow you're inviting Queen h8
Shaq what you said teleporting to aha I
smell Checkmate coin h8
Knight has to go drop back Queen F6
he's done it Queen H a check so let's
see well I can't bring the other night
because that will only invite Rook so I
have to go Knight D7 to f8 Magnus
and queen F6 now is is behaving like you
know he doesn't want to play the only
move on the board which is Knight D7 to
f8
is I
and queen F6 just as you suggested maybe
seven and how do we distract the coin
and in The deflections Rook C6 decoy
Rook C6 Rook B6 could be it Rook C6 Rook
D6 it should be a completely one and
move here but I don't see it ten SEC
night no 96. after Queen F6 he played
Knight G6 depending okay two maybe
oh boy are you channeling your channel
channeling the players as Knight G7
check
it's a killer threat Knight G7 is a
killer threat what are we gonna do about
that
oh oh Magnus down to three seconds two
it's over there is just no move wow we
made a move on one second did he really
but Knight F7 check is gonna
he's gonna lose all of his bits yeah
send it was a piece now
the hearing signs wow after so sorry
after 97 Magnus resigned Magnus resigned
wow great win for radislav Wow Knight G7
bravo bravo as there's a big applause
applause I can hear their Applause from
the audience and we've got and we've got
Warsaw muted
but they're they're other players still
playing an audience but still clapping
that's the way it goes Wesley so is
enjoying a winning Advantage it looks
like to me against dioc and quickly I
wanted to see Anish Geary Duda also
looks like he's playing for a win it
sure does I mean that a pawn is nice but
it's going to be lassoon
okay let's just stay with the Wesley so
game for a moment as we do expect here's
my pick wow you stole them from me he
was going to be my horse
yeah this is uh definitely
it should be an easy win right three
versus one on the same side exactly
yeah I could definitely suffering
because he's and G5 is hanging in uh
chapter 5 king F6 Rook D5 oh nice
what's his game Bravo Wesley as we jump
to our one remaining game and this is
winning this is an extra Pawn but it's
not just the extra Pawn it's the nice
feeling of White's position white
White's pieces weaknesses better in
White's position at all exactly just
have to slowly improve
cursed my my picks I I picked England
and Bucharest as we know dang had a
terrible tournament uh it's a bit early
I would say here because uh dude is down
to 10 seconds so anything can happen
soon seconds yes it's so easy to blunder
when you have no time but it just feels
like he's got 10 seconds in position
um how bad is it uh VAR
it's like plus three here plus and
perhaps he had a little bit stronger
move here I moved Knight C6 instead of
Knight C2 the Knight would have been
very strong there but again I think uh
uh it's technically technically winning
position well I think what Duda really
wants to do is drop his Knight to the C4
square that is like in so many benoni
positions that's always been you know
the key Square in uh yeah and that
weakness on D6 is showing itself it's
like a magnet right like I'm going to
tackle you so after let's say White
Knight gets to see four and black plays
King E7 do we attack with Rook A6 or do
we push E5 E5
oh yes because of the pain and
everything yes
yeah it's just a technical win from here
I I must say this looks like a
good technique though I like I love this
Knight coming to the C4 Square
check doesn't really help
um either King D4 or King D2 both get my
vote again this is what it's all about
we take these this pawn and then
it goes
suffering right now big time and his
answer to Knight C4 maybe immediately E5
right now without even nice because my
king is going to D6
yes and I'm just going for a Checkmate
reminds me of a tigrant petrosi and
Michael bobinick World Championship
Match Game where whites came went all
the way right through the diagonal down
to G7 and checkmated about the Knicks
King on uh the d8 square so I like E5 E5
is excellent here yep and he's done it
as he's looking to go takes and and King
to D6 setting up mating Nets
I always say this to uh beginning
players because they really don't
understand it but in the end game the
king can be an incredibly powerful piece
yes stronger than a knight or a bishop
exactly the king often sets up mating
Nets against the opposing King time
Factor uh they have both about 20
seconds each King X plays itself oh
we're in The Rook end game now
looks completely winning right Rook G7
five yeah threatening Rook E5 check by
the way that's nasty rookie fight there
we go and my wish has to resign four
wide wins in the first round wow uh Wes
Wesley uh yeah everybody uh doing Richie
and let's jump to Warsaw and Christian
and Anastasia
just a perfect start for the Polish
players guys and I just want to show you
a funny moment at the end of this game
between uh voitashek and Magnus because
I believe it was uh Nazi that was
mentioning this move Queen to B7 at this
point after Queen to F6 obviously the
threat is to go Queen to E7 that ends
the game Checkmate in one move you have
to defend that square somehow you have
three options you can go Rook to D7 to
defend it with a rook you can go Knight
to G6 which was magnus's option and you
can go Queen to B7 wish to my eyes and I
think Magnus and Nazi as well and
everybody uh it seems to be the most
practical Choice nevertheless after
Queen to B7 there's a spectacular move
in the position taking advantage that
after Rook 2 C8 check this move out
after Rook to C8 you cannot take that
Rook with either of the pieces you
cannot take with a queen because Queen
to E7 finishes the game you cannot take
it with the Rook because Knight takes D6
I'm going to capture the queen in the
position and that's going to be all she
wrote so this is definitely a beautiful
moment in this game I have to say just
an impeccable uh execution by voitashek
rather slav and I have to say I was
impressed with his compatriot as well
against Anish giri and both of the
players with the black pieces Magnus and
Anish seems to be quite emboldened by
the time format they really are ready to
take some extra chances you can see uh
the opening choice of Anish G6 E6 C5
moving a lot with the pawns creating a
lot of weaknesses transitioning into
some sort of a benoni structure we know
the benoni Is Not Great don't play it at
home kids don't play the benoni I played
it myself but forget about that
nevertheless let's see what happened
because it wasn't as smooth sailing
nevertheless it was yankova that was
making the right decisions so B5
sacrifice upon uh with the sole purpose
of opening up the B file giving the
bishop on G7 in connection with
potentially a rook coming on the B file
some action on the B file especially
that a square B2 the weak Square in Wise
position that's why you see root 2 B8 A4
a692 C3 and Rook to B2 this was uh the
Tactical shot that Anish looked at from
afar when he played the move B5 getting
the pawn back after Bishop takes C3 the
problem is
you have to give up the dark Square
bishop and that's going to allow me to
have potentially uh quite a vicious
attack against your king let's see what
happened A5 Bishop to E3 Bishop to A6
Rook to B1 there was a moment I was
looking through the motion as you can
see okay sure the Black Knight found the
night Square on B4 very very nice
controlling score the problem is you're
not attacking anything you have to
create some weaknesses potentially
looking at that pawn D5 but in order to
weaken the pawn D5 you have to play the
move F5 which in return weakens your own
uh King's position that's why black
plays the move F6 to defend against
Checkmate on G7 Bishop to D2 Knight to
C2 transitioning the Knight to a more
Central Square but once again it's a
beautiful night the problem is it's not
attacking anything and without the
Knight on B4 my forces are ready to
penetrate via the B file and that's
going to create havoc in Black's
position that's exactly what happened
and as we can see uh we see this end
game you guys saw how we finished a very
very beautiful precise win by the Jan
shished of Duda and let's take a look at
what else we have in uh this round I
believe the game but we do have to go
right now because I believe the games
are about to start guys back to you in
the studio well that was fast uh
Christian uh just the results quickly if
you don't mind I see four wins you said
right
after the first round we have four
co-leaders Wesley so Richard rapper Duda
and white tashek or win I'll win and
live on an MPL true and there you go uh
just to remind everybody in the Rapids
they're double points so that was only
uh one game and as we get ready to go to
break
oh pardon me uh the parents that are
coming up right we have Chef chenko
against aronia Geary versus mvl
diaktuda Carlson against the leader
Wesley so nice the Rockford against
voitashek also two leaders very nice as
we pair prepare for a break as we know
we always check in with our friends at Q
Boutique and let me read hear what we
got we got gear up the newest apparel
from St Louis chess club with this
official branded puffy vest features the
chess club's signature logo across the
left breast pocket 100 polyester check
out
cubitystlouis.com and as we go to break
we're going to treat you to some of the
break of the opening ceremonies during
the break see you on the other side
[Music]
welcome to the opening ceremony of
Superbad rapid and Blitz tournament in
Warsaw second leg of grantchester we'll
have the opening ceremony starting soon
withdrawing the floats and of course
with speeches and simultaneous
exhibition just fans are waiting for
Magnus Carlson youngster of Duda so
let's go and see the action
it was great I had a lot of fun seeing
uh Magnus here uh after a very long time
it was definitely exciting for the fans
I think it went very well very grateful
for to Augusta for organizing it
is
[Music]
the simul was quite amazing everybody's
excited to play all these gangsters here
in Poland I think everybody is ready for
at the start of the tournament the games
are going to be absolutely fire it was
amazing opening ceremony all just
friends were happy to play in the
simultaneous exhibition and now let's
get back to the games
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everyone and talk about
starting with a bang here are our
results right we had four wins Wesley
saw Richard rapper Jan Duda and
radoslavoy tashek all winning with the
white pieces a single draw single draw
between LeBron Iranian and mvl
and Mac was starting with a loss welcome
to Warsaw and what about the pairings
coming up um uh we have uh chefchenko
playing against Iranian Geary versus
mviela Carlson against the leader was
Lisa that's a marquee matchup and the
two other leaders Rapport against white
Tasha another one absolutely as we get
ready for round two and again
fighting the bank four out of five and
all with white Pieces by the way is we
saw Magnus Carlson go down but VAR I
mean it was because radislav played
great absolutely he played the amazing
game very precise okay of course Magnus
played a very risky opening the Polish
and you know you know in eventually he
took too many risks G5 G4 in particular
as well sure but wait Ashok played very
very precisely even in time travel he
found this very precise moves at the
very end to finish the game
nicely done what impressed you the only
way to beat Magnus ride you have to make
all the best moves but I gotta say that
from magnus's point of view he was
pushing it even from the very start from
the move one polish uh defense uh 1b5 to
1 D4
but uh hey that's how you become number
one I mean you play for a win with the
white or the black pieces sometimes uh
you get uh
well you you overdo it as we see an
empty stage as the players will shortly
be in stage yeah you've been seeing a
pact packed audience and uh from the
reports from Warsaw just wonderful
Opening Ceremonies that took place
yesterday
and I like the big clap that radislav
got after he won his game well the
matching while the games were still uh
and while the games were still in
progress
and uh when we think of the monarchy
matchup between Magnus and Wesley how
did they match up a whole and they have
a played so many times over
150-ish something like that that's just
rapid
53 wins to 26 losses Wesley's tickled
the him but what I mean having 26 wins
against Magnus that sounds really good
yeah you know right in Rapid chess
you've been you're a player but now
Wesley's playing with the black pieces
even though he started with a win
playing Angry Magnus yes uh two to one
advantage uh in that win ratio for
Magnus but you're absolutely right
playing an angry Magnus extra scary
right yeah and Anglers will come with
the white pieces and what can we expect
VAR from an angry Magnus what does he do
when he's angry I think he's gonna try
to win I wouldn't be surprised if this
is something think unusual again from
him but Wesley is very solid player and
he's very dangerous you know it's rapid
and Blitz formats he just doesn't make
too many mistakes
so so you're saying I made a great
video game absolutely yeah definitely
so the players don't get a very long
break in between the games I think that
more or less there's supposed to be 90
minutes for each round like it's a
schedule and uh sometimes because of the
increment there's not much of a break I
mean you just I mean imagine your
feelings if you're radislava this exact
moment you've just beat Magnus Carlson
what do you want to do
exactly you want to go out with your
buddies celebrate no you got five
minutes and that's it and prepare for
your next round forget and move on you
know what
if I beat Magnus in round one I take a
second look at the price fund
right right I mean come on let's be fair
I mean you just beat the number one seed
in the tournament but we know it doesn't
matter if Magnus starts well or he
doesn't he can come back and beat anyone
at any time so
he is still
looking for that first place yeah yes
absolutely it's dangerous uh even when
wounded no question about it
um I also want to say that the Geary mvl
it's early days
but for Gary who just lost and they lost
two points uh essentially because of the
double score you get in the rapid mvl
kind of a bit of a roller coaster round
one I think he's happy that he got a
point out of that but
something telling me that uh that's
going to be uh anything a lot on the
board here and look at their scores
together they have 27 draws but also 12
wins for unleash and 15 losses so pretty
even Anything Can Happen a very unfairly
honest gets painted with this drawing
reputation but you can see you know if
you take mdl down 12 times and 27 draws
in Rapids you're doing something right
as Anish will look the Snapback what
games of this round two of caught your
eye of r I'm I'm really looking forward
to see how watashek will play this game
against uh Rapport and they both won the
first games they both played really good
games so I think would be interesting to
see if watasha can play another great
game against Rapport in this round and
I'll point out Richie has second white
so he was the first sit in the
tournament right he drew uh number one
as you get two whites now keep in mind
that for the grand Chester players the
the grantchester players have to play in
the classical events and they get two of
the three rapid and Blitz events that
they have to play in this particular
event is featuring a number of wild card
players
including the ultimate Wild Card Magnus
Carlson yeah I love that that's it that
really is an ultimate wild card
and he's wearing his design Puma shoes
the chests shoes that they he had
collaboration with Puma oh
yeah very closely because I really want
to get my hands on are they air Magnus
what do we call it I'm not sure but
they're very cool all right
is
as Wesley is sporting a very new hair
haircut and Magnus isn't
maybe during the tournament if he's not
happy with how it's going he'll get a
haircut exactly so so then we did a okay
yeah but we get a look at the shoes
just a brief look there
like some pretty awesome light sneakers
[Applause]
doing our social media coverage from
Poland Leonard Otis with the blue hair
and photographer just
taking a picture about it that's just
taking a picture of the players and they
are off as they say a wounded Magnus uh
coming out with one D4 when he really
wants to win VAR yes D5 and let's see
have one E4 and all the other games are
D4
only one e4k in Richard rapper white
Tasha game we have the Sicilian and we
see not exactly in London but uh okay
I'll move three Bishop F4 and I tell you
it's just somehow it's getting
increasingly popular this London system
and I'm really not that sure what's so
attractive about it but talk about
fashion C7 C5 and they're in the London
uh are the players uh Magnus Carlson
Wesley so
they
are of London is that it's easy
true you avoid a lot of theory you
sidestep a lot of theory there are some
some tricky dangerous lines that that
black needs to know but if he sidesteps
it all
I always think he comes out pretty
well I mean even by the way Bishop E2 uh
to my eyes this still invites the move
Queen B6 I I think Wesley might just go
for the E6 Bishop D6 variations which
are very very solid and that suits
Wesley style a lot but uh
uh jumping over to you VAR what if you
what's caught your eye a very
interesting opening Choice here we see a
pawn sacrifice already by a niche let's
take a look at the theory here guys so
in this position it started off with
Queen's Gambit accepted okay and E4 is
the the sharpest way to play against
this and now we see E5 comes in trying
to break the center and in this position
we know that the most popular move here
is he takes D4 and their alliance with
Queen takes D4 as well here most popular
move here but black played the move
Knight F6
and now putting pressure on e4 and we
don't have as many games now in the
database still some Bishop C4 now played
and now the pawn only four is hanging so
he takes D4 plate Knight takes D4 and
now castles so we see a position where
there is a pawn sacrifice white has two
Bishops now here and there are a few
options here how to continue only four
games in database some big games by
Mohamed yarov against Dominguez and Luke
Van Valley here again so white can play
the move Bishop A3 here to put pressure
on The Rook and if you play rookie 8 in
this position then there is some serious
trouble here after the move Queen B3
because now it's very difficult to
protect F7 Pawn here so the best move
after Bish battery would be to retreat
with a knight on D6 or play the move C5
and here white can try to put some more
pressure and has the move Knight B5 here
very very complicated line and now there
is pressure on the d8 as well so if you
take the bishop with Knight takes C4
Bishop takes f8
Queen takes seven we see another uh yeah
like the aronian game Knight C7 again
white is a little bit better but still
uh complicated position guys I got it
yeah and and say would you mind please
taking a look at the Wesley so Magnus
Carlson game because you shall we say
the position just blowed up
absolutely and uh so in this position
Knight H5 is is very rare actually
Bishop E2 is already not the most
popular move and Knight H5 a very rare
move attack in the bishop and now Bishop
E5 played F6 and again black is a little
bit weakening the position and the light
squares but now wants to try to get the
bishop in this position so and now c4
played right this is okay first of all
we're kind of in novel territory our
reborn absolutely yeah and then the move
C4 sacrificing a piece I mean uh
what's going on so natural move is
actually just to play Bishop G3 back
after inducing the F6 move and now if
captures white will be I think slightly
better in this position because the
structure is a little bit weakened uh
black can play six can try to you know
claim that you know have two Bishops but
slightly better here for white after the
move C4 but instead he played the moves
C4 here
just a really crazy move trying to open
up the center now the bishop is hanging
so you have to take the bishop okay and
now C takes D5 attack in the Knight
Queen takes D5 and now Knight C3
now you're down a full piece at the
moment but you do have a lot of
compensation after the move let's say
queen d8 you want to play the move D5
deflecting this Knight and then you
capture the pawn on the fire with your
knight threatening the move Bishop B5
checks so I see some compensation here
for white but they're really a crazy
position guys well boy uh
and by the way he didn't take the bishop
Wesley said I was just gonna say that I
wouldn't touch that Bishop either it
takes the bishop takes on D5 takes nd5
Knight C3 I kinda get it although
walking into this line when Magnus is
prepared and you're not uh rapid yeah
but you know a piece has a piece uh I
don't quite see the refutation I almost
Checkmate is Bishop H5 anything or you
just play G6 I think I can just uh for
the moment at least yeah I know what you
mean it's almost Checkmate but
almost
that's a check now that's a Checkmate I
would of course have to play Queen and
uh I get my king
um a peace sacrifice Wesley said it kind
of what you were saying there too you
know see that uh hey look I'm not about
to to let you have your fun E7 E6 drop
back with your Bishop just as VAR has
been suggesting you do and uh I'll take
that or you can take first on D5 I think
this is better he did take it yeah CD
and then Bishop G3 right so you get it
so kind of an isolated Queen Pawn in the
offing but on F6 yes
so definitely um good Advantage for
white right you don't feel good about
the pawn on F6 now having said that okay
uh
at the moment you're having Castle I
Really Wanna I Wanna Be Active
Queen to B6 because I am thinking I want
to grab that pawn I think I would castle
and let you take the pawn right so
castles let me take this guy now I I
waited specifically for you to Castle so
that you didn't want to play King F1 and
leave your Rook on H1 and now I'll just
ask the key question Queen takes B2
Knight here and I don't know uh either
captures or even C4 just saying yeah I
mean prove yourself yeah not not that I
don't think white has great compensation
I think white has Fine composition but
at least you know prove yourself that's
why I would find myself attracted to
Queen B6 did Wesley make a movie he's
thinking
I think it's always important whenever
you're starting the next round uh is you
look at the guys who are leading I mean
I think it's respectful so let's just
jump to the game of Richie versus
radislav for a moment because it was a
crazy
Bishop B5 check it's a night off churned
it's early A4 A5 Dragon dwarf Dragon
door
and A6 and then comes D3 B5
this is weird stuff I don't even know
what this is called a jump in VAR what a
what am I looking at let's just call it
Sicilian yeah open Sicilian yeah it
definitely obscure uh a sicilian we have
here there are still three games played
in a database in this position here and
uh one game by a very young American
Grandmaster Mishra so and uh here's a
youngest ever younger Sarah absolutely
so here Queen takes B6
played in all three games in this
position and then of course the move
Knight C4 will be played putting
pressure on the queen and then you can
go let's say queen C7 the idea is to
play Bishop F3 right attack in The Rook
this A5 Pawn is really weak right now
black is up a pawn actually you have you
know four and yeah you're up upon here
but white needs to try to get one of the
pawns back eventually uh black is going
to give up one of the pawns like Bishop
B7 here
so we're gonna see something like this
bishop takes Queen takes Rook A5 and uh
Rook takes A5 Knight A5 and the Knight
will eventually come back on C4 with a
very very slightly better position but I
think uh black is actually doing fine
here
thank you for that uh VAR uh sorry I'm
just finding myself once again drawn to
the game between Magnus and Wesley I
don't know what it is about magnus's
games but I mean he I mean he really is
a magnet and he's playing a very
interesting line when we left it uh he
uh Wesley immediately took on G3 wasn't
even waiting uh for the decision to
Castle and Then followed up with C5 C4
a2a3 clearly uh Magnus does not want to
see Bishop B Ford check and the
potential for a trade on C3 so he played
A3 here he's also looking at the
potential of playing Queen C2 E4 if
Black's Pawn wasn't on F6 if it was on
F7 I would say black is great I'd like
black bishops one on C4 would be great
agreed how do we fix that exactly I mean
you're might as well inside some ways
just suggest you know like I'm going to
have to play F5 so you do it you go like
Bishop E6 so one of the things I if I'm
in black shoes I really don't want to
see E4 come because when E4 when the
move E3 E4 is played it undermines my
Pawn on C4 like any trades where I get
to go Queen takes E4 and I go to so I'm
thinking that whether you like it or not
the move F6 F5 does two things it's it
stops E4
but it also kind of
proves that you move F7 F6 is an
absolutely absolutely terrible uh once
again because the Rook is on H1 I'm
start looking how can I exploit that and
remove Quincy too should white even
Castle short because of open Age file
maybe black should think about long
Castle I I'm thinking that I wouldn't
mind just okay let's say I play Queen C2
let's just put Queen seeds oops Point 93
so it's black to move let's say queen D7
for example perfect Queen D7 Queen C2
and yeah I I genuinely am thinking of
Rook takes H7 let's say I Castle long
H7 at the moment I have Bishop F5 I
agree I agree with that
um well E4 D4 is hanging yeah but E6 is
hanging
um I'm having a hard time just uh
on this one
because if you play E4 your king is
still in the center as well yeah I'm
gonna play King F1 to G1
um
I'm just thinking how am I supposed to
be doing this okay let's uh I go B3
so it's a little bit after all
I I'm trying to uh suggest that maybe
your king is an ultra save
yeah I'm not sure if I should take it or
leave it on C4
I'm probably going to force you one day
to take it
the desirable E4 why I resisted playing
e-force first of all because my king is
still in the center not because I was
afraid so much of Knight takes E4 I just
didn't feel like I had a very good
response to the move uh Bishop to F5 and
if my King's still in the center I felt
a little bit awkward so I went B3 one
idea guys after Queen D7 in the current
position there is interesting move
Bishop takes C4 ah
and to try to play D5 very quickly
Bishop takes C4 and D5 yeah
slight Advantage for white at the end
because you have a nice leading
development actually I I like that move
very much because it also it keeps my
Rook alive and trading off a light
squared Bishops uh feels right by the
way Magnus made we have few moves on the
board matters played B3 a very sensible
move I went Queen C2 and B3 Magnus said
well yes can't we save a Tempo and play
B3 right away and then we took Wesley
took and now it's Castle in long I would
be afraid walking right into open BNC
file exactly exactly in those cases and
now I think yeah I would play with
castles maybe black should just play
King F7 and live the king there
very easy for us to say King S7 leave
the king there
um how are we how are we supposed to be
defending the B7 Pawn say after Rook B1
I don't want to play B6 so I guess Rook
B8 yeah V6 my intention of course was
Queen A4 Bishop B5 by the way I didn't
mean King F7 immediately maybe developed
the black square at Bishop first sure
and just instead of castling eventually
go king of seven oh okay Bishop E7 first
makes sense so Rook B1 Rook B8 yeah
something like this and now at last uh
let me try to exploit so maybe now king
of seven
you're living a
dangerous life here 26 it will just take
yes it takes H7 La Petite combination we
do have Rook C8 on the board and I like
that move by Wesley because it basically
says
I do see the potential of the B7 Pawn
becoming weak I can defend it by Rook C7
yes Knight B5 can chase me away but big
deal also maybe he wants to play Knight
A5 nights before if he has time for it
makes sense makes sense
always you have to be just mindful at
least if the movie should be fine but I
do like this move work CD
um VAR Jump Right In please uh
how does the engines assess the position
is it novel are we in novel uh territory
yes there are no games played in this
position and white is better here I
would personally play the move Castle
here and try to put my Rooks or Rook fc1
Rook a B1 and I think white is clearly
better here the pressure on B file and
also D5 Pawn is weak but there is
another move in this position that
computers like the movies Knight H4 here
the idea is to play just simply Knight
G6 here and this this one was actually
forcing the mood that you probably don't
want to play the move Rook G8 because
then you can no longer Castle so just
the the Knight H4 main point is just to
provoke this move of G8 because there is
no other good way to stop the move
Knight G6 here so after move Rook G8 you
just you can just castle and then follow
it up with the same idea Rook fc1
through kb1 kb1 and uh you know slightly
better position for white but black
still have the pair of division so I
think he does have some chances later on
in the game in particular I like this
idea of Knight A5 Knight C4 you guys
mentioned so slightly better for Magnus
at the moment and give it that far just
turning our attention to Anish Gary
versus nvl that was that pawn sacrifice
and the more I'm looking the position I
really enjoy anisha's position because
first of all
the extra Pawn that black is enjoying is
a double Pawn so that that that
diminishes the quality of the extra Pawn
then second if you just kind of look at
the two Bishops you can see that this
bishop is being really some very awkward
kind of pressure this bishop is doing
yeoman's work this bishop on C8 a little
bit passive sometimes the queen might
saddle up to A5
attacking Pawn on C7 so I'm
finding it easier to play anish's
position let's just jump to Carol versus
Lavon position this is a queen's Indian
defense a very famous pawn sacrifice you
you lose the pawn on C4
Catalan yeah Queen's Indian Catalan
because it's a closed Catalan right with
the C7 C6 but you sacrifice a pawn you
get your big Center and the theory has
always been kind of vague
H4 Bishop H3 is interesting I like it
not common in Catalan the shop stays on
their diagonal right it almost looks
like a Boris Gulf and uh kind of idea
I've seen Boris do these things a lot in
his favorite kinds of catalans where
he's playing for G4 G5
but lavon's rolling with the punches
saying I'm not interested in opening up
the a file and as long as you're not
capturing me on C4 I'll just complete my
development I'll keep an eye on the D5
Square probably I'll throw in H7 H6 as
needed and show me what you got for the
Palm milk was positioned
against Robert let's go there
I don't know if black is actually better
but I like what I see uh when we left it
we were like a pawn up there goes our
extra Pawn
we come back are you three
I don't know if black has something
immediate here
maybe because you can always take right
I would love to play F5 but I hate
Knight G5
uh but wait a minute
this is I have a good follow-up okay 95.
because the point is if you can get H6
in and you can chase away the Knight
White's pieces look daft
it's a that's what my mother says
British britishism he she he didn't play
F5 he took on B2 he just kind of sold
Bishop takes B2 and okay at a certain
moment you want to play C4
I don't see any problems whatsoever for
black in fact I kind of liking the fact
that this bishop is staring down the
bishop on B2 slight pin and I feel black
is really doing very well let me jump to
the Wesley so game
um Not Just Happening no updates and
finally game we haven't seen at all
diach versus Duda easy for me to say by
the way Dia versus dude ah this is uh
grandfather a grunfeld
with the early E3 oh this reminds me of
a game I played with Carrie
where I played B4 but it's a different
move order so like you see this position
what you have right here and what I
played with Gary
was uh
Bishop to G5 Knight to E4 takes tags
takes E6 right back
takes E3 castles B4
this was my game of Gary and very
similar yeah exactly they just got here
kind of a different way before uh A4
let's go so the minority attack two
Bishops minority attack I think overall
black is happy he has no specific
weaknesses that white is can nibble on
well White's overall strategical idea is
to plant a night on C5 and that's why we
see due to playing the move
A5 just to be as disruptive as possible
I assume we're about to see tanks takes
in something like Rook A7 or even Queen
C7
um balance position looks pretty equal
what do you where would you like to take
this uh you know see what game has
caught your eye earlier
looks very interesting whoa Queen C5 now
that
is not for the faint of heart you play a
move Queen C5 you have to be very very
confident that after Bishop takes F6 she
takes F6 you can hold your king side
together
this position just terrible Queen F4 is
one of those triple threats C7 will also
be hanging exactly the trick don't don't
think for a second I haven't uh imagined
that the Fawn on C7 is hanging Bishop E4
love this move uh to my way of thinking
that's an introduction to a Rover a rook
up and over are you just getting out of
the way and in the meanwhile by the way
yes I'm very interested in recapturing
the pawn it looks to me like mvl is on
the back foot on issues enjoying the
moment uh we'll leave it there and again
we'll pop in on Wesley for a moment
because we did see Magnus playing
well I would say a little bit of a
peculiar move I I guess he's prepping
against Knight A5 he's stopping Nate
well yeah stopping 985 is strong but
stepping away from Knight A5 but I have
to tell you VAR you you you you you had
me with the move Knight H4 that move I
found particularly attractive not just
because you're threatening uh Knight G6
but it's this whole idea of exploiting
the potential light squares Bishop H5
check Bishop F3 why didn't he play
Knight H4 what what what what what
dissuade him from playing Knight H4 I'm
not exactly sure but perhaps he probably
wants to bring this Knight back at some
point uh maybe even like Castle Rook fc1
Knight E1 Knight D3 I've seen this idea
before trying to bring the Knight to F4
yeah because it will be very well placed
there putting pressure on the bishop and
on B5 he probably thought if I play an
ih4 he plays Rook G8 then I don't really
have too many prospects for that night
to go from there the move Queen B2 is
fine I think he's still slightly better
here but it's it's not that big of an
advantage here Wesley should play the
move Bishop E7 here and just try to get
ready to Castle here but once again a
queen B2 prophylaxis but what is the
thinking where's the logic explain the
logic of Queen B2 a queen B2 I think
it's mainly doesn't want to be hit by a
temple with Knight A5 so like yeah I
will show you now in this position so
now Knight F5 would you can't even play
this move now anymore because now you
have to move Bishop uh B5 coming up but
in a in a in a previous variations I can
actually get my Knight Knight F5 Tempo
and then put it on C4 black kid in the
bishop in some of this lines but after
the move Queen B2 here Wesley can play
Bishop E7 right and I think he wants to
play the move Knight D2 the Knight is
not doing anything on F3 here on F6 is
actually restricting it so putting it on
D2 is is I think one of his ideas and
possible after the castle he can even
play the move Knight to B3 Knight on B3
is actually doing two things threading
at some point to go Knight C5 but also
most important thing you control the A5
Square so the opponent cannot go there
and then you want to play castle here
and then rook fc1 and again look for
opportunity to play the move Knight C5
at some point so this would be a
slightly better position and the big
problem for black is going to be this
permanent weakness on the fight that you
always have to have one of your pieces
protect so it's going to be like we
should have three ideas putting pressure
on the fact that's why this is a
long-term Advantage for white
all right thank you for that I like that
idea of moving the queen down so your
knight can take the B3 Square it's a
very long term plan the these
prophylactic measures of always kind of
confounded me in the sense that I was
always looking for the most direct you
know for saying I love the plan of
Knight H4 and Knight G6 I also love the
plan of 91 to D3 to F4 you tickle the
bishop you tickle the palm and it just
feels so much better on F4 but putting
the Knight on B3 defensively minded the
stop Knight A5 that's like a groaner to
start with and then the idea that you go
to C5 it just feels like okay okay but
hey this is uh Chess at the highest
level this prophylaxis prophylactic
measures are vital jumping into our
tournament leaders Richard
Richie and radislav we saw a surprise
from me
Rook takes because I felt that that that
was what white wanted uh the queen
protects the bishop which means this
this this pin has been subdued but
actually the queen on A1 looks really
good I mean it could bounce to A7 it
could bounce to A5 it did and it did
Queen A7 give me the bishop Queen B8
wanna trade
no thanks I'll defend my Bishop we were
talking about round one the C file you
know everybody loaded up on the C file
you know
an overlaid yeah overlaided elevator on
the C file here I can see that the B
file might be well trafficked in the
very near future by the way gifts meet
the pawn Queen C7 will invite me to play
Knight B5 so for the moment I think
there's still some some problems to
solve uh at least Richie's Queen to my
way of thinking is active on A3 and that
earlier fear that I had of C5 C4 is
dissipated and I think white is doing
fine
uh back over to you VAR what what has
caught your attention it looks like
maybe Levon missed something here and
here Chef jenko has a really strong uh
possibility here Levon just played the
move Bishop before here he should have
you know and here white should play the
move E5 here the best move here for
black would have been to play Rook cd8
or even Knight f8 just to wait for a
moment you always need to watch out for
this move E5 and here actually E5 is
very strong because you're attacking the
Knight and if you play Knight D5 Knight
takes D5 you cannot recapture
immediately because the bishop is
hanging so you play the move Bishop D2
it looks like after the recapture you
just take back CD and you're going to be
very happy but there is this very nice
idea Knight F6 check first in between if
you take back with the pawn then your
king uh position is going to be
compromised and you're really really
weak weak and good attacking chances
there so you need to take back with the
Knight on F6 and how you take back with
the Knight on D2 the Knight is still
hanging on F6 and if you play the move
Knight D5 the Knight E4 4 comes in and
now this Knight is going to land on day
six and I think also there's a potential
with the move Knight G5 so the white is
actually going to be much better in this
position so big opportunity for
chefchenko to play E5
nice thank you for that and uh Nasi
couldn't help but point out to me that
Wesley's King has landed on F7 as she
suggested uh quite some time ago uh King
on F7 for white and by the way the same
petite combination that I was trying to
do when your king was on F7 a time ago
Queen B1 by Magna so the idea here is I
want to take and G6 now because Queen is
on B1 so so this is of course the petite
combination
King G7 yeah give me the words
hello who's attacking
hello so I have to come back
oh okay
we'll come back
but here I also had some other ideas
like night Discovery moves right I would
say yes right that was the one that I
but you're right you you do have some
discoveries against my night you could
take or but the move maybe which is a
little bit weird is F5 right
yeah the bishop is like
oh man
and we don't have G6 on the board
Wesley's not afraid of this combination
oh okay G7 G6 maybe well if this
combination isn't working then black
king can go to G7 and it's completely
fine right and why did I play Queen B1
because for sure Magnus was thinking uh
he has played the movie at 92. I was
about to say if you don't go Rook takes
H7 and
there was this loose night right the so
92 King G7 let's say it's perhaps at
Knight F4 Bishop F7 now this is a
different kettle of fish here the king
feels very secure the Bishops
uh really look well defended and there's
no Rook H7 combinations uh whatsoever
um Wesley landed on his uh
Wesley landed on his feet uh bar
absolutely Wesley slightly better yes
sir two Bishops yeah absolutely yeah he
will play Bishop D6 now then he has a
very very clear plan what he wants to do
he wants to play six Knight A5 B5 and uh
very clear at the meantime white it's
it's unclear what is White gonna do you
don't have any breakthroughs on a king
side you don't really want to play the
movie four anymore because I will just
open up the position which will help
black and if you stay passively then
black is just going to expand on the
queen side here and do you have that big
problem on A3 that pawn on A3 eventually
going to become weak as well here so
Knight F4 Bishop F7 played and Castle so
castles yeah that takes away all the
pressure from the age trial as well now
gave up on the H file yeah but I gotta
tell you if I'm in Wesley shoes it's a
sense of relief even though the Rook
takes H7 wasn't really there it's just
that now I feel like okay my King's
perfectly safe and I can start thinking
about you know using my queen side
Knight A5 maybe on a good day even
double the Rooks on the C file why not
so 95 95 Rook C3 is also another option
after that yeah just put some pressure
on A3
I like it I like it it looks very
comfortable uh Wesley is one of those
players where he's with you he just
stays with you it's like a kind of a
joke of it she's returning the ball he's
staying with you he's in the game he's
in the game and if you slip
don't be surprised when Wesley says no
no no draw
and uh what's happening in the MBL uh
game bar uh looks like mvl is slightly
better here uh actually it just just
about equal actually sorry in this
position there were some combinations
here so let's take a look so Bishop E4
after you played so very interesting way
to develop the bishop here the move Bish
bass six came in I didn't see that the
point is now your queen is protecting
the bishop if you take immediately roof
takes E4 here will come in and now
Bishop takes C6 attacking both Rooks
eight and E8 Bishop takes F1
and now Rook takes F1
Queen E5 centralizing the queen
and here a white needs to create a love
saw H3 is expected move and now I think
black needs to start out with the move
A5 here now so because A7 Pawn will be
hanging a lot of the variations but now
the queen is actually protecting that
pawn so
and let's say you can play Move C4
and now Rook
eb8 Bishop takes E8 you take back with a
rook
and uh spot structure is a little bit
weakened but it's not as much material
left on the board here very small plus
here for white but I think with accurate
play probably black will hold this
position
so thank you very and can you also
please show us rapper the way Tasha came
because I see that radoslav got C4 in
somehow yes so C4 is just played in this
position and he also had the option to
play Bishop takes E4 in this position
that would have been fine as well Bishop
takes E4 D takes E4 and play something
like e6ish controlling the dark squares
and there's a very very good Bishop here
on G7 and 90s actually out of place only
for black is doing absolutely fine
perhaps even slightly better here if he
had taken only four but he actually
played the move C4 and now Knight ec5
play this is the current position here
black should take on C5
it just takes on D3
and you're going to end up with the
isolated Pawn here so if anything black
is better in this position so C takes D3
for example
and now you can play the move Bishop C8
or you want to move Bishop C6 series
D4 Knight D7 we're gonna see some
exchanges now
and we do have a few moves being made
um I think they exchange The Exchange
yeah yeah so there there is a
possibility that we'll see some
exchanges and if the position can fizzle
out to a draw at some point one exciting
game that's going on also is between
Carol and Lavon it's one of those
positions where you got two Bishops
versus two knights uh not the type of
imbalance we're used to seeing at the
very elite level but in lavon's case
he's got a pawn to go with the two
knights uh White has the
Dynamic classical Central Pawn Duo again
two Bishops versus two knights extra
Pawn for uh
surprised me I was expecting more like
Chief workout all in go all in G4 G5
let's go
um I must say I'm I'm a provocateur so I
love it when my opponent does that type
of thing because I feel that it's kind
of one of those Bridge burning moves G4
you lift your kimono in front of your
king always your king is a little bit
weak Bishop F1 Queen B4 Rook E3 and for
me uh
as black I am always mindful this bishop
is in Ambush right I'm always mindful of
the dynamic grade d65 if I could keep an
eye on that maybe I I like the move
Knight f8 just a little bit
keeping uh
control if you will on the D5 Square
here also well I'm again maybe it's too
provocative but C5
with the idea C4 and B5 I think C5
definitely invites D5 yes
exactly it does it's a bit risky unless
immediate C4 is working yeah it's quite
dangerous yeah that's what I'm thinking
that I do want to play C4 with the idea
of B5 trying to shut down the Bishops
this is a double-edged very sharp
position is time a factor I wanted to
ask uh not yet Levon has 12 minutes and
kiril has about eight minutes by the way
Queen f8 by Lavon
trying to be safe super safe right upon
up uh do your worst uh what's it going
to be
and it's like one of those things when I
play C4 C5 you play D5 I want to trade
and immediately put a knight on D6 the
old blockading night so it's possible
that the move Queen f8 is a Prelude to a
knight E8 maneuver uh sorry once again
what did you say about the clock eight
minutes versus 12 and a2a4 I like this
move this is a kind of move where you
don't know
um mm-hmm
when black is going to push his pawns
but you know it's kind of so you might
as well get in the move A4 as a you know
as something to stop this majority you
know uh early I like the move A4
it's definitely ready to
respond with D5 if after C5 exactly so
it's like a waiting game Black's waiting
for white to attack on the king side
White's waiting for black to push C5 and
exactly uh just you you're feeling in
general would you rather be white
definitely definitely because you like
the initiative you like it during and
like I would be very happy to be black
like very happy to be back exactly I
mean this is a type of position for
where both players can be happy uh I
agree uh I don't like the last movie
won't play Queen f8 I think it's a
little bit too passive he should have I
think played the move B5 which would
have allowed him some options like
Knight B6 Knight C4 and you know just
just to keep white thinking about you
know at some point in the night is going
to get active here and after Queen f8 A4
is a great move because now you don't
have the B5 option it's it's very hard
now to move actually for black because
you don't have E5 you know if you play
C5 you're gonna run into D5 and your
lights goes are really weak so I find
this easier to play for white there are
more options in fact earlier than Nazi
mentioned that G4 G5 is actually a very
strong idea as well instead of the move
Bishop F1 few moves ago G4 G5 was the
top top suggestion for engines to
continue the aggressive play on the king
side yeah the more I'm looking at this
move A4 another very very good reason
for playing A4 I was always thinking
that the bishop was going to be
operating on the long diagonal in truth
the move Bishop A3 could be very
annoying especially for example if you
were to drop back hoping to re-maneuver
your knights in some beautiful fashion
Bishop A3
is undercut set by the way I'm being
told there is a repetition that has
occur that is occurring between a niche
and MBL at the moment Shack check we
just had a couple of checks I don't
think Anisha is ready to throw in the
towel with the draw
especially because after like okay like
after check King G7 I can take the Rook
followed by Queen Bee salad slide Edge
for white but nothing serious right
nothing serious but hey I mean you you
you're the one with the damaged goods I
mean your King on G7 and the pawn I if I
was white I'd be taking the Rook on an
A8 I'd be making Luft either with H3 or
G3 and I would just say okay
let's see where it goes we'll keep an
eye on that one back to magnus's game
because a lot has happened indeed when
we left it we just left it here we saw
the move Bishop F7 we thought Wesley was
doing fine Knight A5 fits in perfectly
with Wesley's strategy of utilizing his
Queen side structure E4
maybe not the most joyful moment for for
for Magnus to get in the movie E4
it should be if he didn't want to get
slightly worse passive position so
instead he opened things up more and
oh wow 95 lost well exactly this move
night this whole maneuver Knight D6 very
characteristic of uh a check bernoni
which I love to play I just think that
Black's night is just so gorgeous here
Knight E5 that's an indication to me
that Magnus is very very uncomfortable
he doesn't want to see you know a queen
G4 land or something Knight E5 why can I
take that right I mean
I'm so happy yeah exactly why can't I
take that takes text and take on e4 okay
what can I do I'm gonna take on e4 F5
and queen F5 am I just up a piece yes
you are uh but there are two points
and by the way he didn't even take
we we sorry we we don't even get a
chance to look at the peace sacrifice
he played Queen E7 almost without
thinking he says I respect Magnus and
I'm sure he has something prepared I
don't I'm not interested says Wesley
Queen E7 and by the way I wanted to say
just about the check but only for just a
moment
uh I'm I'm used to having this Pawn on
F7 but this Knight is gorgeous if you
don't get to play rookie six I would say
you're strategically lost
as uh black but if as white but if you
teleport your Rook to the E6 Square
you've got chances right now I just
think that the Knight versus the bishop
and no contest is going on right now if
white can activate pieces really fast
yeah yeah then white will be better but
if we look at this positionally why it's
Pawn structure is not great and like you
said the Knight versus Bishop 90 is
definitely better no contest so the one
thing I don't want to see is rookie one
rookie six so I'm assuming Wesley is
planning Rook E8 so that you make my day
if you play rookie one I I will trade
everything and I I claim game but rookie
one is not what Magnus is going to do is
a clock's a factor oh yes so Wesley's
down until five minutes okay and Magnus
has 11 minutes again a two to one
advantage quite a big advantage on the
clock Magnus had the same time Advantage
I want to say in the first game of game
he lost and this move Queen before okay
that post up we could definitely be
supportive of because again Rook E1 Rook
E6 even at the cost of the pawn if that
bishop ever gets Unleashed on D5 then is
good Rook to C4 Queen to D2
and VAR jump in I'm overstating for sure
what Wesley wants but
it's not so easy to keep Magnus under
lock and key here he's got his ideas
absolutely yeah current position is more
or less equal here but Wesley had an
opportunity or a few moves earlier when
the 95 move was played yes if you if you
go back a few moves right there 95 95 is
not the best and the best move there was
Knight D4 and position is about to equal
after 95 a very strong move is Queen A4
Queen A4
so you're forcing the move Knight takes
F7 and after King takes F7 if you move
the bishop I simply take the pawn on F4
that's cool you're actually winning a
pawn here and black would have had a
nice Advantage here after Queen F4
that's very very comfy so and of course
if he wanted to make a draw he could
have just simply take the Knight that's
the line you guys were looking at it
take only five Ponte C5 Knight takes E4
Queen takes E4 and just move Rook H E8 I
was looking at the idea is when you play
E6 just simply sacrifice Bishop takes C6
back eliminating this past Queen takes
Queen B7 and rookie seven it looks like
it will be very very easy draw here so
I'm not sure if Wesley is playing for a
win but he had a few options here after
the move Knight E5 the current position
is about equal again the dangerous you
know white landing and Landing a rook at
some point only six but it's not going
to be easy to do it and with some
exchanges of the Rooks in in the long
run actually black would be better in
this position if we get an end game with
the queen and Knight versus queen and
Bishop for example that could be a big
problem here for Magnus well I do see
Queen C5 Rook C2 on Wesley's agenda
please you know I'm going to try to
guess magnus's next move it's gonna be
F5
which is your dream boat A variation
because suddenly the bishop comes
crashing in on the party and if I don't
don't take you go King G7 well then
you've traded off a weakness oh no he
didn't play it right there but your
logic was impeccable I love the logic F5
was a good move yeah definitely
exchanged the Pawns yeah well a three a
four kind of borrowing the page of Carol
for a moment you know taking care of the
queen side majority but now having
suggested that f4f5 is on White's agenda
uh black should qualified well no I I'm
thinking black should get in his
his uh punches
by the way we do have a draw a
repetition between Anisha and bl let's
stay with um Magnus for a second I'm
thinking if I'm Wesley I want to play
Rook C2 in Queen C5 ASAP he played
Quincy 5 first okay uh which is you know
right
and quickly Rook E7
yeah I think was this playing fast
because he's down to four minutes and he
doesn't want to get into complete time
travel down a few seconds so a couple of
fast moves
uh at times uh Wesley is so very very
practical uh move rookie said I I tell
you it's one of these positions where if
Magnus doesn't have a bishop D5 if
Magnus doesn't have an F or F5
um
he could easily end up in a position
where he's simply very very passive I
think um the he's going to try to have a
contra play if he tried to exchange
coins every time you go to C7 he's going
to try to get a contra play on the
e-file with the move like Queen E3 for
example so you do need to keep that Rook
on
E7 to make sure that that Rook Never
Lands only six as well it's a position
is equal but I find with the time
situation Magnus is going to try to
press here I could see him playing G3
King G2 at some point I I didn't like
the fact that he usually allowed this
Pawn on A5 I wanted him to play the move
B6 earlier when he had the chance
instead of the move Queen C5 because the
pawn on A4 would have been I think a
little bit weaker Here and Now on A5
your B7 Pawn is going to be hanging in
some positions as soon as you move the
knight from D6 position is is equal
again but I think with the time
situation it's just a little bit easier
to play for Magnus Rook C7 uh played on
the board does invite Queen E3 you're
eyeballing there upon on A7 you're
eyeballing the E6 Square
I suppose uh that the immediate Queen E3
would invite I don't know a trade of I I
somehow I like the F4 pie yeah it's
double but it's also a good one yeah and
I do like very much your suggestion of
G3 and King G2 who knows sometimes the H
file can be a very good Avenue of attack
Rook C7 on the board here here guys G3
is going to be not as good I think
because the move Queen C3
G3 Queen C3 that's a nice one if I think
we need to rookie seven and yeah you're
gonna Force the exchange of Queens for
sure you're taking away my my intended
Queen E3 ID of me I should go back you
have F5 series F5 absolutely F5 is a
move here and start looking at Queen H6
ideas
and uh oh yeah because Queensland C4 the
tactic still works right if not a 5d6
exactly the same in my Bishop oh he
played it okay yay
Leslie has three and a half minutes
Magnus eight minutes
in this particular case now the move
Queen E3
doesn't really first take on G6 right so
there's yeah 10.95 correct so the first
stage takes Queen E3 ice no
and we do have a trade on G6
we do have Queen E3 give me the pawn on
A7 I'm saying Queen C5 I'm inviting
Queen
E6
and my intention was actually to do
nothing
but but it's uncomfortable it's there
yeah he's posted it up it has Magnus but
okay for the moment
I was about to say for the moment Rook
F7 I don't see
how you're going to improve like my
knight my Rook
I was with the Rook on C7 by the way my
intention had been to play B5 a b a b
and push my beep up create a passphone
yeah go baby counter play you let's do
it he did he played Rook S7 VAR Jump
Right In thank you first of all the
engines assessment evenish uh no it's
better not for Magnus better for Mac
yeah Wesley has just played a few moves
passively and now G3 he wants to you
know example and play King G2 so uh so
you could say Wesley drifted a little
bit a little bit yeah after G3 your B5
move is an option to try to create a
pass Pawn uh but after that white can
play King G2 just not even taking on
passan and uh
if you let's say play the move before
then there is a problem now after the
move King G2 a white has a threat and
that threat is actually very very strong
it's the move Queen H3
Now setting up the move Rook H1 right
it's going to be some serious problems
on the H file who opened up the H file
sort of like who Let The Dogs Out ooh
yeah no I see that Queen H3 nice
um
yeah I wasn't a big fan
and by the way Richie and radislav all
smiles as the two co-leaders make a draw
and as we know the draw is worth one
point in Rapid so both of those players
will go to three out of four uh after
two rounds and we're we're following the
game between Magnus Carlson Wesley so
for those of you who are joining us late
is on H3 hello hello
uh Magnus went down in round one to
radislav and it was a
it was play on one goal I want to say
Magnus really did get destroyed in that
game
by the way uh Queen H3 that is a very
uncomfortable Wesley so
as VAR explained Rook to H1 Queen h8
will be mate she played Quincy
trade of Queens best move
okay Ken white hide the queen somewhere
so that you can still threaten Rook H1
maybe Queen H2 or is that too passive
well I'm thinking Queen age eight is on
Black's agenda I wanted to play Bishop
G4 until maybe Queen h8 again right uh
forcing the trade of Queens even at the
cost of allowing the bishop to E6 a
queen trade would be a dream for Wesley
then I think no more checkmates I like
this move Queen C8 bar good absolutely
great great defensive move and oh trade
56.
oh I think a lot of exchanges happening
leading to an equal end game
uh Rook takes D6 there's there's some
positions that are equal
I've always felt that rook and Bishop
versus rook and Knight they were the
bishop
where the where there's pawns on both
sides of the board by the way Knight
takes D6 on the board I think if you if
if Wesley had played Rook takes I'm not
interested in trading Rooks but I am
interested in playing rookies or you can
play rookie one here yesterday that wins
The Pawn on A7 after Rook D6 yeah rookie
one because now the Knight has no
squares to go to you have to go to
create and then after capturing on C8
you can win the a pawn and again that
position is not clear if we're gonna win
that even but right uh
convert a lot of Joyce Rook end games
right now uh Knight takes D6
A6 or Bishop C6 or what do we like
yeah both moves are playable but I think
black is fine The Rook will go on d8 and
then you're gonna play F5 King F6 and
you you don't really have a way to win
that A7 pawn and uh it's just it's just
equal at the moment
okay so it optically the pin is not
meaningful then
okay we'll keep an eye on the defense
for black an easy defense easy for you
to say of course Carol versus Lavon uh
we left it some time ago but we catch up
with the players right now and Lavon is
enjoying life he's actually traded
Queens which is a big success he's
currently a pawn up and uh White still
has a lot to prove he's also up on the
clock he has five minutes versus one
yeah it looks pretty equal
well equal or once again I I like the
extra Pawn
well there's Rook C5 Rooks a seven well
excuse me just a second Rook C5 Knight
takes E4 Rook C7 give me a hakasito
and let me take this guy I'll let you
take this guy
and I was going to take this guy and I
could have played King F3 and make you
take with the Knight ah maybe that was a
better option for sure maybe
and
well
aren't you a little bit worried that
your king might get you know one of
those H5 Knight G4 types of dudas
avoided all this he played E5 he played
e of five
takes takes no tip yeah E5 here E5 here
so he's inviting Knight G4 right
say 94 as well
defendant C5 or 94 as well
uh I would for some reason I was afraid
of Bishop C6 was I right to be afraid of
Bishop C6 it's a rook D4 and
we would exchange C Pawn for the a pawn
black would be upper part yes that looks
pretty good yeah
uh in time trouble that's so actually I
have a problem uh 94 is attractive but
so is Knight G4 uh clear the cobwebs
what's wrong with Knight G4 VAR um 94
display but I was looking at it the Rook
takes C5 will be played Knight G4 Rook
takes E5 check yeah and I was looking at
Rook D2 immediately but let's Okay
immediately there is a F4 and looks like
uh wow it looks a little bit dangerous
but look white white has enough Contra
play because you're gonna win this a
pawn and uh that like Rook C8 Rook C7 at
some point and then you have good Contra
play so but if we played The Rook D1
check instead yeah so let's take a look
at G2 Rook D2 yes King G2 Rook D2 and
then this this King F3 is very strong
now King F3 I kind of my pieces are a
little goofy yeah yeah Knight takes F2
or wait a minute no H5 yeah H5 is a move
and then
CA check
uh-huh King H7 King H7 and here uh by
the way I'll introduce ourselves to say
that after some thought Lavon was
attracted to Knight G4 he did play the
move Knight E4 after all
yes so
and I will point out that our one of our
leaders Duda who started with a win who
we forgot about thank you yes also has a
very good position in this game
trying to um yes
by the way night for some reason the
sitting on D2 and the game of Lavon but
let's switch to the doodar game because
I do see that that's on our board there
oh this is the
has two minutes
I'm seeing visually I'm seeing a knight
coming to C4 and I'm loving that if I'm
black if I can get the Knight to C4 at
defense B6 and Bishop can also go to F5
which looks also nice
yeah black looks like there's a lot of
options
by the way I love the bishop F5 more
active pieces
yeah very unpleasant for white
right
by the way I thought I saw Derek just
reaching for the bishop on F3 it's not
doing much there's no uh sacrifices but
this night coming to see Force too
strong uh Bishop to E2 you think you
should take I would I I wouldn't want
that Knight to live on C4 too long so
then we would have two Bishops versus
two knights yeah
exactly a straight two Bishops versus
two knights and by the way just uh to
say that Wesley's held on I mean an
angry Madness with the white pieces
didn't end Wesley and uh we we think a
repetition is actually in store at the
moment
maybe not in repetition yet but it
definitely looks like a dragon game
gosh for some strange reason I thought
the players were repeating position
um so on rookie six will black just play
98 or
uh Magnus has just played Rook E6 and
you're right 98. you you called it
before he could play yes I suppose he's
ready to meet Bishop A4 with Rook
E7 you always have to be careful about
those King and pawn end games right or
is that a ridiculous idea for white to
jump into a King and banan King yeah you
can't I think black is holding though
but yeah you have to calculate because
after Bishop A4 you you really have no
moves but to play the move so that could
might be better because A6 is over
pushed then maybe black can win that
pawn well I mean it's one of those crazy
races right
yeah but maybe the table base will tell
us
something
it looks like a draw yeah is it
well
I don't know but uh let's jump back to
the game between dioc and eduta because
there was no Knight C4 there was no
Bishop F5 and somehow the bishop
magically jumped
B7
that's a straight wow Rook B7
why is it two days down to 20 seconds 20
seconds up to 45.
I think to this may be not clear on the
plan and he's just making a couple of
moves too sure uh solid chess uh varve
solid chest but
yeah a little bit passive absolutely I
think do that differently the last few
moves were not not the best uh here I
think I like white now Queen C2 yeah
setting up a little tactic with Bishop
G6 so opponent needs to watch out he's
played 90 too that's another good move
as well because then you finally want to
bring that knight from G2 just been
doing nothing there for a long time you
bring it to F4 and you have some
pressure yeah pressure on G6 pressure on
C6 now this B6 Pawn needs some attention
as well so I'm beginning to like White's
position by the way the move Knight E2
also threatened Queen C2 kind of a
strange double attack right I'm ready to
take on C6 but I'm also ready to take on
G6 and after Knight C4 Rook B2 B5 the
game is really heating up
taking would have been better absolutely
he had to take on C4 so B7 B5 pardon me
B6 B5
both players are 20 seconds but I will
say white wine on the king side Black's
playing on the queen side and a whole
will be
stronger quicker exactly take your pick
um night setting up by setting up
sacrifices whether they be on H5 or G6
and queen D6 ignoring
is Knight H5 ridiculous I suppose it is
you can take and play Bishop G7 but it's
something I would think about after all
White's play is all on the king side as
you were mentioning now see 10 seconds
and counting fast four oh my God
touch the closest piece of the clock
right exactly uh something about this
move I like because after B3 you can
play Bishop to C2
and maybe night oh he took on E6 that is
a surprise I think when you're down to
five seconds
you just can't really calculate anything
just make a move and he's done it so
Rook A1 Rook A2 DX lost uh the thread
here bar yeah absolutely by the way
Levon is now winning chefchenko made a
huge blunder guys at some point we can
look at it he he had a basically a draw
but then he just made a really big
blunder I think Levon is going to win
this game now okay I will stay with this
one just because of the time clock
situation we're invested
again down five seconds Rook A2 E2
finally getting back on track to where
his trumps lie his trumps are on the
king side and in the center this move
clearly
uh telegraphs E3 E4
Knight A5
um
Now or Never let's do it no go E4 Bishop
C2 remarkable restraint I would Wild
Horses couldn't have stopped me from
playing D4 in that position get that
pawn going okay he's stopping D3
is he going to play Knight E1 to D3
again a lot of maneuvering to and froing
I know it's actually not helpful when
you have too many options and you have
five seconds on the clock it'd be way
better if you had only moves exactly
sometimes it's so much simpler when you
the path is narrow Bishop f8 is before
preparing he does it he played E4 I took
him so long
I mean E3 E4 that's where
the Trump is you've got to do it and
Rook takes E4 suddenly suddenly
I mean yeah the clouds have parted
there's some action for white on a good
day night to F3 to G5 Rook E8 is
suggestive
uh pardon me rookie this game Anything
Can Happen through oh three results for
sure it it felt like two results for a
moment but now three Knight F3 here we
go white
why I don't know it could be 65 quickly
just to open things up C5
again I've been told that Magnus and
Wesley are definitely heading towards
remiss
uh King G2 a useful little move
um I would have been probably more
invested in Rook F4 but okay Rook E7
maybe E5 now I like done I like that
move I like that move a lot in fact
rookie five uh Queen D rookie five Queen
D3 rookie five Queen E2 he made that
move with one second on the clock one
second oh dear okay Queen D3 Queen A6
let's go come on
it's not enough time to think just that
yeah but that move
gosh I don't like that movement in my
mind that kind of invites I hate
being pinned and I hate allowing my
opponent to pin me like Queen E4 Bishop
C2 Queen D5 why did I allow the PIN
Rooks he won
yeah I'm liking black again now yeah
it's amazing how the advantage can twist
and turn with each move Bishop D6 useful
as was King g72 by the way
draw Magnus against Wesley Magnus is not
gonna like day one
of the Warsaw Rapids having a great
start though first game win and then
holding Magnus with the black pieces
that's a brilliant start by the way they
are really playing so defensively minded
these last few minutes they've both
gained some time they're up to half a
minute down from five seconds so that's
something
but still time disappears so quickly
again and we we talk about rook and
Bishop for a second I don't say it's
winning or anything like that but just
to clarify who's got the event and Levon
has won his game
welcome back to the Grand Chester or
Lavon aronian uh and he started with two
black pieces first two games
which means he's got the last uh number
uh Rook A7 I was about to suggest Knight
takes B3 Queen takes B3 Queen D5 with
the Rook on E7 would have clarified the
rook and Bishop versus rook and Knight
setup which I think would have favored
Levon apart I just saw lavon's face
I I think black is uh much better had he
played Knight takes B3 a move ago
now with the bishop coming to E4 I gotta
say I feel that all three results
impossible I think you're both playing
for a win
no I really think diach has been trying
to hold for some time but now having
said that
wow
but last 30 moves have been all made
with 10 seconds
for both boys yeah so okay I'm actually
amazed neither of them have made any
blunders yes right well it's too early
right but yeah I I was about to say with
the bishop
when you're no longer pinned with the
bishop on e4 you really start to think
can I get away with Knight G5 rookie 3
Rook F3 you really start heading in
those directions paduda also put in
pressure on the queen side because his
b-pawn is a very nice pass Bond yep if
he can manage to push it without losing
it
that would oh rookie three I like that
move too but hello
may I introduce maybe it's not so great
knight C4 Knight C4 is looking very good
because that forces Bishop C4 and he's
done it and he's done it in a nice way
because once again
it's working Bishop
by the way uh Queen takes
and this one Queen D5 is so strong you
start to think
yeah D4 D5 in order
now after Queen day five again he played
with two seconds on the clock so yeah we
can't judge this players for not finding
the best moves right with no time I
think
they're just playing intuitively making
moves as quickly as possible but do that
definitely looking like he can be as
Soul Leader now if he wants this oh
absolutely no question about it you
start there now rookie servant is very
strong guys just exchange the Rooks
rookie seven the night yeah I was about
to say
I like his move I I really find myself
attracted to the move Bishop F6 because
on a good day if I get to play Bishops
pardon me C5 with my Bishop already on
F6
my position please I mean my roof looks
good on A7 attacking A4 right Queen D1
no time how much time did he how many
seconds two seconds again two seconds
Bishop F6 or C5 C5 because we're pinned
now again uh the only reason for Queen
D1 was that I could play Rook E5 against
C5
so rookie five I'm sure was DX intention
rookie five now Queen D7
asking A4 attacking A4 I guess winning
A4 right
because white cannot defend it yes
uh but E7 is oh but I can't take it
right not yet
takes and this is
now it's looking like a two result game
suddenly now if Rook D5 then Queen takes
A4 right exactly so I'm thinking Rook B
for 085
thought he was going to play Rook B5 for
a moment
and now
what The Rook C3 coming if I have time
for it
Let's Play Bishop F6 inviting Rook D5
Queen E6
[Music]
A5 is hanging he's got to stay on the
fifth rank but he didn't want to walk
into that pit Rook D5 Queen E6 would
have been deadly Rook C5 push D3 yeah D3
D2 very quickly this feels like D3 Queen
takes B4 where we're closing in on
Victory for black but four seconds Queen
gate is a great move because now you
cannot take on before Bishop E7 nice no
he also wants to play Rook takes A5 now
so excellent move queen d8 that he found
with four seconds locked on the clock
yes King G2 Rook takes A5 Queen takes B4
oh wait I just saw DX reaction I think
he just blundered that pawn well I think
he actually played it well King G2 you
know sometimes
you make what you think is a blunder and
it turns out that maybe it was the best
move D3 but now aren't I in time to set
up some kind of a blockade
Queen
no Queen E3 maybe allows Bishop C3 I'm
not sure I like that so white has to
start with Knight D2 yeah and I'm
looking at Queen check as being the most
annoying right
for his night
by the way diox Queen is somewhere
between C5 and C6 but it's on it's
supposed to be on C5 right but it's not
what we would call Centralized
okay G1 so now Queen A1 check then uh
practically speaking
um what's your impression of this ending
this is completely winning completely
winning just just needs to play
accurately this the fact that this Pawn
reached D3 it made a whole difference if
you're somehow blockaded the spawn on D4
I would think if you're with a knight on
the two I think you're probably holding
this pretty comfortably but with the
panel D3 I think you just uh you're just
simply not going to be able to hold
because this bishop C3 idea will always
be there and then eventually pushing the
pawn on the two and we know the queen
end games are lost as well here question
if the Queen's got exchanged I thought
Duda was thinking maybe to play Queen C3
would that be winning well let's take a
look so Little Queenie one yeah Queen
City was also winning yeah actually and
now I play Queen E1
the Queenie one is on the board uh
funnily enough I was attracted to
Queenie one because I saw Knight F3
Queen E4 he played Queen E3 and he's
getting the same ending right yeah for
white so so why can't he just take on I
think he's oh he went Queen E2 which he
could have taken on E3 and played Bishop
C3 what was the answer
oh yeah yeah that was winning as well
absolutely uh he could have trade and
Bishop C3 the line goes Knight E4 slash
Bishop E1 and then you have a very
important move Bishop E1 yeah yeah the
idea is you're gonna meet no no no 94
actually I apologize if Knight B1 just
Bishop before and the Knight is trapped
on B1 and now you're playing 9 13 F5
King F1 you have F5 so what has happened
is they have traded and he has played
Bishop E3 King to F2 I guess it's time
for why this kind of insukswang right
well he's gonna play E4
F5
very important
you were waiting for me to suggest what
move I had in mind what white had in
mind was E4 and King F2 he did he he
stopped it with F5 I think this is it F5
was a brilliant last move last time
Final Touch yeah now black is winning
and I feel like we're gonna have the
Applause again guys
by the way uh for Duda I mean the Polish
audience must be going wild all right at
this exact moment saying holy smokes we
just had radislav winning with
winning a crushingly over world number
one Magnus and the college players
really fill in the Home Advantage two
out of two or four out of four if you
will and Knight H3
uh teasing the possibility of Bishop uh
should we worry about the G6 Pawn or
just go King E5 King E4 I think it's
time just to push him yeah King E5 well
let's have a look Knight F no he didn't
even play
he wasn't interested in allowing King E4
no maybe bishop E1 or that doesn't do
much I know it does a lot because you
are threatening E2 right and followed by
Bishop takes G3 or Bishop takes G3 right
away nice yes maybe that's even nicer
right Bishop takes G3 oh pardon me this
is a check so we have to play E2
King E2 only move now well there's 93
checkpoint
right that doesn't 90 D3 is just kind of
a temporary 93 King F6 and we lose
everybody so we can just take G3 H4 now
right
okay so King F6 is more precise maybe
King F6 I like that because G3 is ours
anyways preset Bingo the king but I'm
gonna play King F6 Knight G2 I have to
play Knight G2 Bishop takes King takes
maybe I can resist
he played Knight D5 by the way so
I think was this a step in the wrong
direction bar I'm not a fan
I think black can pick up the nh4 now
yes that's precisely what I'm worried
about uh yeah I think now it's just uh I
if he left his Knight on G2 oh E4 again
is going out and with the one second on
the clock no way really he has done that
just in this game
and he's a thrill seeker by the way if I
take Knight C3 I can Queen
no you take with the night oh that's
fine you take with the Knight I take on
on G3
right
no E3 doesn't do it okay just king of
six simple bring the king choose that I
wanted him yeah I wanted to play
brilliantly with D1 equals Queen
anytime yeah I can goes to G4 and
picking up both Pawns
that that sure makes life a lot more
simple doesn't it
Jack was hoping maybe to get some just
each pawn and the bishop
but unlikely
to happen
uh impressive play by dudas he's
outplayed his opponent very
comprehensively I would say more
absolutely yeah Duda could have just
taken on G3 and H4 and just win that end
game as well because you cannot
sacrifice the night for that pawn uh but
I think this is the way he's playing
it's just much much better here
now Bishop takes G3 something to be said
for King takes 395 King takes H4 and
just and just like the h-pan of course
yeah King takes H4 Knight takes G6 King
G3 and you can sacrifice the Knight for
one pawn and there he has it he's one
two out of two four out of four big
round of applause
I am telling you
uh they love it but it's that's really
moment when you're the last person on
stage and you know all the applauses for
you not not the guy down the down the
road let's jump over to Warsaw and
Christian for uh inside view
well I didn't know there's a thing such
as home court advantage in chess you
don't have the screaming fans throughout
the game but you definitely have them
afterwards and you could see that after
this game it definitely seems like there
is a home court advantage for the two
polish players and let's take a look at
what happened in this game between dayak
and aduda that you guys just caught the
end of and this was a battle of intent
from the early get-go it felt like black
Duda that is was playing for a victory
and I have to say that he was playing
quite passively throughout this game and
take a look at this you have the
groomfeld early on i2f3 Bishop to G7 E3
already have a very passive approach you
don't go for the main lines we take you
on D5 E4 or maybe H4 uh the move that
we've seen in Fabiano's game against mvl
from the previous step of the
grandchester that explosive game so
definitely a very passive approach by
Bogdan Daniel dag and we ended up in
this position take a look at the this
structure and this structure we're going
to see for a very long time this is move
I believe something along the lines of
move 20 after the move H4 and this
particular structure lasted for the next
20 moves no pawns were removed but I
have to say I'm looking at the
weaknesses in the position you see the
pawn on B6 that's a weakness for a black
nicely defended by the Nikon D7 you see
the weakness on A4 that's nicely
defended by the Knight on C3 but you
also see this imbalance between the E3
pawn and the C6 pawn and you would love
to attack the C6 Pawn as white the
problem is you cannot get to that pawn
because the Knight on C3 is blocking the
action of your Rook so at this point it
just feels like black has
um a blank page you can do whatever he
wants he can wait and at some point
improve the pieces to the maximum which
is what Duda did take a look at this
Shuffle the pieces a little bit white
doesn't have any active plans you cannot
really play E4 because that's going to
create another weakness in your position
the pawn on D4 so let's take a look at
what happened Rook to A8 Rook to E1
Queen to F6 a lot of shuffling of the
pieces and this was the critical moment
right now Queen to d8 to defend the pawn
on a B6 and free up the Knight on D7
that is the one piece that you need to
improve in this position and do the
found the right plan as we will see in
the next few moves Queen to B3 Rook to
B8 Bishop to F3 and now finally the
Knight is going towards its ideal Square
in the position the square C4 and that's
where it landed and by the way take a
look at this move this timing of B5 was
just absolutely spectacular and I have
to say this is probably the move that
gave do the uh the advantage not
necessarily decisive advantage in the
game but definitely a practical
Advantage once again he was the one
pushing and you guys saw how this game
ended take a look at this game between
uh the two leaders going in some two of
the leaders going into this event uh
into the second round Richie report and
radoslav voitashek take a look at what
happened in this one another Bishop to
B5 check game by Richie Rapport we've
seen this type of Matt rossolimo because
this is with D6 but this bishop B5 land
in the Sicilian as well now we have the
move A4 that's one of the options you
have to stop A6 and B5 how do you do
that by playing either A4 or C4 in this
type of uh line and Richie chooses the
line with A4 it's very thematic you just
want to get as much space as possible on
the queen side make life difficult for
black on the queen side but again this
is all Theory and you guys were
mentioning that as well during the
broadcast now this is a battle once
again a structural battle in this
position as we can see white has the
nice compact uh structure black has a
lot of of lonely pawns the pawn on A4
the pawn on C5 but take a look at how
this changes with the next few moves
Rook do you want A3 a very good move I'm
changing one of my weaknesses in the
position and later on I will change the
second weakness in my position the pawn
on C5 and right now it is white who has
a weakness a lonely Pawn on a D3 so
everything changed in the last few moves
I have to say
probably outplayed a little bit Richie
Rapport in this one but Richie was very
smart and he decided to simplify the
position exchange everything and the
players surely agree to a draw later on
Exchange absolutely everything easy draw
for radoslavoit the two polish players
are definitely feeling the energy coming
from the fans in the first couple of
games guys
students thank you Christian home court
advantage indeed but let's take a look
at our standings after two rounds or in
the history books we have a soul leader
Paul is the perfect score and closely
following Wesley's show I live on
Iranian Richard Rapport and Corrado
slavoit
MBL is
Carlson languishing with my pick Anish
giri in a tie for seventh and as we go
to break people Christian with our guest
Adam
uh lemon topic
I hope you enjoy
we are here with Adam lamentovich the
CEO of superbet Poland Adam first of all
welcome to the show tell us a bit about
this growing connection between chess
and the Superbad foundation and Superbad
yeah it's a fourth time uh we are
running this show as a super good
foundation second time in Poland but we
are with grantchester since 2020 so it's
really a repetitive journey and with
every every year it's it's really more
fun and and we are more engaged into it
so a really great experience and and
great to be here and great to host so
many great players in Poland and also in
other countries where uh where the tour
takes place uh but but in Poland we are
really proud to host all these stars for
the second time and it's not only
repetitive but I have to say you guys
are getting better and better with each
and every
um iteration of this super bad
tournament and I have to say that big
board in the middle of uh Warsaw is just
incredible and the QR code everybody
passes by scans the QR codes and gets
connected to the tournament how did that
idea come about well uh we are growing
business and uh and also you know uh we
are quite good in activating not also
our other sports sponsorships we we
treat our engagement with grantchester
and super better Robin and Blades is one
of our big projects across the year so
uh activating this event the weather is
great it's it's good season in Poland so
people out on the streets so create
creating a a big chassis in central
focal point of the city inviting
YouTubers Young influencers from the
Chess World I mean this is definitely
the at the heart of this event because
uh this event is not only about of
course promoting grandchester super
foundation and our brand but it's mainly
about promoting chess uh as a game and
as connection with uniting people and
and
exercising and improving our our
thoughts in mind so I think it's uh it
was natural move and as you said I mean
uh we are getting better into it as as
we saw what what has worked well uh last
year and and we simply try to to improve
on top of that and how did you see that
impact the numbers because yesterday we
had that big chess game between the
influencers the YouTubers as you were
mentioning how did you see that impact
the numbers of young players joining
jazz
I mean uh
we see basically the room is totally
packed there are over 150 people outside
of a poly Museum right now this is
waiting to get in waiting to get in so I
think also uh we have reached a
completely different level of
penetrating and and reaching out to
people uh informing about this event uh
this year so uh of course uh we had lots
of Spectators last year but but this
year the room is packed uh museum is
full uh plus a huge line in front of in
front of the museum so
um I think it's uh it's great it's great
and we take learnings also for the next
year uh to to prepare even better to to
to be able to address all those
Spectators and it also helps that you
guys have some amazing players in Poland
as well do that the defending Champion
here in Warsaw and and also radhesla
voitashek the Local Hero I think he
lives here in Warsaw so that's uh that's
really great and and today both of them
play with uh Magnus so it's a it's a
it's a unique opportunity uh first day
uh with
um both polish players
playing Magnus on the first day and I
think it's uh it's great great
collection of uh of real Champs and and
of course Magnus is a great star we we
could see it also during the opening
ceremony how many questions towards him
so yeah the Stars definitely aligned
with those first couple of games Thank
you very much Adam for joining us thank
you thanks a lot and right now we are
going to go to a commercial break uh
don't forget the games are going to
continue stay tuned
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
here we are in Warsaw I'm ready for the
round three of Superbad rabbit and Blitz
and actually there are so many people
here the atmosphere is so great and if
you want to go to the fan zone of this
tournament or if you want to come to the
Players Lounge area you can follow our
social media accounts and see all these
backstage material so please don't
forget to come to our Instagram account
to Twitter to Facebook and make be sure
you will have so many extra material
there yes so we are really looking
forward to the round three and now we
are going back to the studio to yaser
and Nazi and War
thank you Anastasia as round three is
underway
um I'm looking and what do you do when
your Magnus Carlson you need to win with
black by Carol Khan absolutely yes sir
as he is up against uh yanduda who has
started four out of four I tell you what
look at magnus's uh never mind the
hairstyle that's one thing but this his
body language is like what am I doing
what am I doing what's going on uh the
old variation the classic variation with
Knight d7r
absolutely yes sir he's not playing
Bishop 5 he's he's definitely trying to
win this game he it's a very slow start
slow start for him and we know from this
rapid events two points you get for a
win usually players who do well in this
rapid tournament and that winning this
uh portion of the event so it's very
important to try to get some points in a
rapid section as well and uh yeah he
didn't play Bishop P5 so he's playing
the 97 line here and uh so I think we're
gonna see the move Knight F6 yeah it's
funny that he's pausing because if he
were gonna play he takes F6 you wouldn't
have committed your 1967 if you were
going to go g takes F6 you wouldn't have
done that but as Magnus is uh studying
the situation lay the table for our
audience and I'll see what we have for
the parents right we have boy tashek
playing chefchenko who has no points
Carol needs to get it back into the
tournament Wesley Cell playing Richard
rapper to tournament leaders going head
to head and our Soul Leader dude up
playing Magnus Carlson right by Shayla
grave against the yuck once again MBL
looking at diak across the board say you
have no points I'm going to take
advantage and aronian against Gary
Aniston good start so Lavon saying hey
we're the win
I could be doing very very well and
again uh going back to Magnus Magnus did
eventually recapture uh with the night
night takes c2c3 Bishop G4 on the board
and this is just classic Karo Khan
variation uh what is caught your
attention bar I was just checking this
game actually just to see there's lots
of theory in this position still yes
there are about 200 games played 200 yes
and this C3 move and now H3 is very
important to try to question this bishop
and I think the best option after that
is just to take on F3 which has happened
yeah let's take a look why for example
you need to do that because if you go
back Bishop H5 if you say oh I want to
keep my Bishop then you're going to get
into some serious trouble after move G4
Bishop G6 and now Knight E5 comes in
and oftentimes you're gonna run into
ideas like h4h5 and you are behind in
development and moving the bishop so
many times could be could be problematic
you do have a way to save your Bishop
here but after Bishop before F3 uh
Bishop D5 you you're just losing lots of
tempos and white will be slightly
slightly better here right uh let's take
a look at the the Wesley game here we
see a benoni type of position here and
uh Wesley Wesley plays really well this
position so I find this a little bit
risky what report is doing and uh
strategically here eventually Knight
Will land on C4 at some point and there
is a pressure on B6 at the moment it's a
nice nice Advantage for white and we are
out of theory at the moment so B6 could
be played here
for black but then you play the move
King H1 eventually you're preparing to
move F4 and E4 immediately slightly
better position for Wesley I see in this
matchup
thank you for that
or I'm looking at the game
you know it's it's strange these old
Indian variations uh that radislav and
Carol are playing takes me back to some
kind of teenage Hood where I really
studied uh carefully uh the writings of
David bronstein
and David hurt my hurt my brain
he caught
he calmly kept me thinking and
um I always have this trouble uh looking
at the game between radislava and Carol
trying to figure out if the pawn on D6
is a weak Pawn or Untouchable pond
because it like so many times
you you think it's you know backward on
an open file and I'll just I'll just
double up and triple up and somehow
black manages I don't know through
through counter attacks against C4 he
gets an A5 A4 and bronstein made the
positions work for him as black I
couldn't did you ever try these old
Indians or did you just steer away I
love playing against them against them
yes I prefer this with white okay and we
just have this move h2h3 uh Knight H5
maybe the bishop just stops drops back
and then you go all out with that four
but you have to be careful because again
I have just seen so many times
after ideas of A5 A4 and queen A5 that
black gets in his shots as well Magnus
strangely enough has just gone for the
imbalance of the two Bishops you would
think that from such a position you
would be happy as white but Magnus is
basically saying I don't think uh the
two Bishops are
anything and you know I'm going to just
I don't know play for C5 and or E5
I would think that Duda would be happy
he's like for sure I'm leading the
tournament and I don't see him no risk
position yeah I don't see how I'm gonna
lose it so um definitely press for more
here plays C4 and Bishop C3 and slowly
slowly the only thing is don't
um leave yourself you know like you you
don't want to miss time your move C4 uh
mvl versus diac okay very classical
position not much to say both sides have
put their Knights on the king side and
over the the board kind of tilted to the
king's side as the pieces all moved uh
student body right Lavon versus Anish uh
let's see this is a little bit weird is
this a Vienna yeah with Knight C3 right
a Bishop's opening with Knight C3 kind
of turns into Vienna when I was white
and I played these positions I was
playing them for F4 not the way
Lavon has played it by the way just to
point out that Knight takes C3 doesn't
win upon thanks to Queen E1 and the pawn
on E5 is hanging this is all Theory up
to
and the lifetime scores between these
two while lebronica has a quite a big
lid yes 20 wins nine losses and 22 draws
which goes to show how LeBron in Rapid
is really a formidable Force H3 Bishop
H5 caught up with the players uh Jump
Right In VAR this
position it's Theory but uh what do the
statistics tell us uh there was only one
game played actually before the move
Rook 88 and after Rook 88 I don't have
any games in my database here so at the
moment I think white is maybe slightly
better here and I'm just curious
why he played the muruk 88 because in
this position Knight B6 was the move
played in that one game uh by
Grandmaster Ernst and after that the
game ended in a draw but the Mover kd8
is actually allowing the move Rook takes
B7 so I'm wondering if there is
something that Anish missed here because
he tried to trap The Rook that's my
reaction to play the move Knight B6 try
to trap it but you don't have a good way
to attack this so of course we don't
want to allow the move Knight C4 so
we'll just simply play the move Bishop
B3
and you need to you need to attack it
but how to attack this Rook here that's
the question it's very hard to see uh
you know we don't have a way to bring
the bishop back so what if I take a
straightforward approach which like
Queen D7 Queen yeah let's take a look at
that but then this this runs into a big
problem here Knight takes E5 attacking
your queen if you take only one there's
gonna be Knight takes D7 that's just
simply winning and if you take with the
Knight back Queen takes H5 and now your
knight is hanging only five and if you
play Queen C8 there is Rook takes B6 and
simply captured only five so this is
just winning for white so I'm not sure
what Anish means I think there is a
chance he maybe makes something because
Rook takes B7 just wins uh wins one more
look Rook takes B7 Knight B6 Bishop C3
um
okay yeah so it's right it's right a
trap the night with a future Knight d85.
but here actually white can play very
aggressively you know there are two
options I see here one is to play with
C4 but let's take a look at the very
direct idea G4 I have Bishop G6 H4
usually trying to trap the bishop yes oh
my H6 H6 H5
Bishop comes back Chief is what he wants
wow this is just very direct
but who who's the king age eight
King h8 if you take on H6 the G file
opens maybe I'm the first to yeah I
don't think he wants to take he wants to
not play the move C4 switch
and now play for C5 at some point now C5
takes Rook takes C7 ideas wow this looks
very risky for white yeah I mean it's
double-edged stuff I I uh okay double
extra but Rook takes B7 I'm with you uh
that is definitely take the pawn
definitely and uh radislav Carol okay
that that one we've seen diat that one
we've seen Wesley Richard game is quite
interesting because we have benoni very
yeah but this benoni with E2 E3 as
opposed to E4 has its own Dynamics and I
must say that in this particular benoni
uh White's King is much safer yes in
other words
put the pawn on e4 the white Pawn on e4
put the black Pawn on F4 and the
Dynamics on the king side are much more
favorable
for black with the pawn on E3 you're not
killing me over there not at all so it
feels more of a one-sided game because I
can play on the Quint side yeah full
full out right no attack on the king
side at least not yet exactly so Knight
A6 by the way you always I'm looking I'm
looking I'm supposing that Queen takes
the night before with the ideas of Rook
B8 and Knight C2 are sufficient
and
I have a lot of good moves here please
tell me uh
okay a2d1 looks fine pretty sure B5
maybe bishop B5 I'm seeing from Black's
perspective that he wants to plan a
night here and maybe on a good day here
so would you like to play Rook D1 right
before are you playing for Knight C4 uh
let's see who do you want or do you want
to play
okay right here you have another
approach you have F4
so F4 it looks a little bit weird but
here's here's the thought that
once you get an E4
with the Rook
it seems like I'm still giving black
counter Play Chances on the king side
yeah and I would prefer to have it like
one-sided you watch your cake and you
eat it too get it I got it uh uh
interesting uh sorry and Magnus
uh boy that that game sure looks like
it's blistering its way to a draw uh
over to you bar what caught your eye
yeah I think this game is most likely
we're going to see a draw after Bishop
takes F6 at the moment in in a Wesley so
game in that structure you guys were
analyzing yeah I want to point out this
move that is I think very important
Bishop B5 is a very very good deal right
here Bishop B5 oh B5 Bishop B5 sorry
yeah because it's like what yeah you
want to exchange the light Square
Bishops in this position because as we
can see there is a weak Square on E6 and
the dream would be at some point to land
the Knight there sometimes 92 Knight F4
ideas and again if you play a move G5
that that really weakens the position as
well so Bishop B5 would be a nice
Advantage for Wesley to uh take us
through it Bishop B5 Knight to B4 this
should be five Knight takes before
I don't see a knight landing on E6
immediately yeah so here actually in
this position it's okay now to take
already only five eliminate the Knight
okay because the point is now the Knight
is going to lend to the desired Square
on C4 Bishop E5 Bishop E5 Knight C4 and
if I put my Rook on E8 yes you can play
it okay am I worried about F4 and E4 at
some point yeah I will play I will start
out with the move Rook 81 and I can feel
that E4 F4 and E4 is on your agenda yes
at some point I'm planning to do that 92
is another idea at some point here's 92
perhaps even bring the Knight to F4 just
a knight on C4 is just incredibly strong
in this but only structures where you're
always putting pressure on D6
so this would be a you know slightly
better position for white all right so
thank you that Wesley versus Richie very
important game is those two players
starting nicely with three out of four
again two points for a win in the Rapids
quite I think also mvl has a very
pleasant position when we looked earlier
it was still Theory right but now it
looks like white got everything they
wanted well the classical Central Pawn
Duo that is for sure uh D4 E4 very nice
King looks a little bit funky uh
on age seven here I mean you're always
you I don't like encouraging my opponent
to connect come get me right and the
King on the Long die on that diagonal
kind of encourages Knight F5 Queen C7
Knight F5 oh my gosh this has all
happened
um I think White's playing on the king
side and in the center
and I can't even play I like Rook C1
here
bow
well is it
it's not like this are you possible I'm
not 100 sure you are but okay I'll I'll
uh ah now you wanna
understand now you want to just take and
take and win the pawn that was why you
played Rook C1 so I guess I have to stay
with you
uh I'll get off
now broken A8 is unhappy so true I'm
happy with what I achieved yeah true
true but
could I be threatening E4 and D5
foreign
[Music]
s but no I don't think so I might even
just go
I'm I'm afraid to allow Bishop H6 there
are issues here there's no question
about it there are issues and by the way
8384 yeah uh now can black play E4 D5
very quickly let's say start with E4
let's have a look see E4 okay Knight
goes back to H2
um should I sacrifice on B5 sacrifice
what what sacrilege
sacrifice a pawn
I'm just worried if I don't play D5
right away is white going to play D5
maybe so if for for example we just
throw in B4 you you're concerned about
losing my E4 Pawn
true but on the other hand you know as
Bobby Fischer famously said to get
squares you you got to give him and
you're getting a pretty good Square yeah
it's too good you know even if you were
to win the pond somehow this night on C5
uh VAR very interesting game going on
between mvl and dioc but we kind of
think this move A4 is an indication that
mbl's happy with this position
absolutely mvl is happy I think the move
Knight F5 he perhaps rushed a little bit
at that point the evaluation was quite
big for him he could have just waited on
that let me pull out that game for a
second sure I was looking at another
game so in this position after the move
Queen C7 I really like this idea Rook C1
coming in open file getting the open
file and now Queen has to move cannot
sit there and uh it's it's not so clear
to see where you put this queen because
you put it on ba then you don't have the
connection between the Rooks if you put
it on E7 at some point there might be
some problems on the e-file here like
here in this case Knight F5 I really
like because now we're going to take
advantage of the fact that Queen is on
that file against The Rook so this would
have been I think a little bit bigger
Advantage for him because after Knight
f8 capture it's very important that this
Knight has this f8 Square to go to
because now there is a blockade on the
F5 and um
now we play the move A4
white is still better here but the best
option here for black to go is E4 and I
think you might have mentioned this idea
to try to play to attack this Knight and
the Knight goes to H2
and now Rook e C8
putting pressure on the bishop
and if the bishop goes on B3 it's
important to start with this stroke
because we're going to take on A4 we
want to make sure the Rook is no longer
hanging on the E8 so we don't lose a
Tempo now to move the Rook away and here
you can even you have a few options you
can play this move Knight
fa2d7 uh very slightly better here for y
but I think black and definitely defend
this position with apologies with the
Rook C8 Rook C1 instead of moving the
bishop to B3 or C1 yes yeah I mean I
want to tit protat you attack me sure I
think uh here's uh Queen D7 will be the
best option now now attacking the pawn
on F5 Knight G4 Knight G4 and then
Knight takes G4 HG and now just clamp
the center with the move D5
and um I was hoping that F6 and or G5
was going to get me something but yeah
the G5 and F5 is hanging right now so
is F3 too clumsy F3 in this position
it's a possibility I think in this case
now we takes A4
we take only four twice exactly twice
and then Rook a B8 putting some pressure
on B2
um
fair enough yeah it's it's it's unclear
actually the position okay because I
think Magnus is having some fun because
after 29 moves he has more time on the
clock than he started with
Morton
okay uh by the way uh Magnus is uh clock
management has been Stellar uh not
necessarily these positions better but
his management has been seller
uh but what I wanted to say was once
again this this crazy position between
redislav and Carol this is like one of
those games again that confounded me
David bronstein somehow if you look at
Black's position right here right now
it's sort of like
okay black achieve something I mean this
Knight is like resting on this really
nice Square let's see what exactly
happened temporary activity I think
right I don't know I don't know
sometimes that temporary becomes longer
lasting than you expected Knight's on F3
okay again so let's let's
just uh go with the obvious so I want to
take the Rook I have to play Roku too
rookie too and let's see uh
gosh so I'm playing Bishop G2 next
I still don't know how
I'm going to continue on they showed you
two next uh
yeah night hmm
even if a white position is still better
it's definitely easier to apply for
black Maiden well but how how exactly am
I going to start sacrificing my my bits
and pieces here
uh should I be putting my knight on
E5 5095 and pawn G5 if needed well this
one this one right
this one this one
um tricky tricky stuff going on here
between uh uh uh
and kiero help us out uh VAR uh the the
Knight on F3 makes a great impression is
it temporary or long-lasting I think
it's temporarily and with accurate play
now white is going to remove that knight
from F3 and it will have a slightly
better position yeah I can show you the
next few moves here sure so in this
position I think taking with the Rook is
the best so Rook takes E6 right Rook E2
right we move and now I think it's
logical to double up the Rooks okay and
now play the move Bishop G2
putting pressure on the Knight and the
Knight can Retreat actually also on G5
but only five it looks a lot more
logical right so now you're putting
pressure on C4 and here white has two
options here you can play the move Queen
B3 this is basically combining the
defense of the C4 and also putting some
pressure on B7 also you can play a move
like
B3 in this position too
I was trying to avoid that because I was
worried about Knight C4
uh B takes C4 queen queen C3 at the end
of that line the B7 Pawn is hanging
and you're not worried about Queen take
C4 and queen takes C4 and there is a
strong move Rook C2 attacking the queen
and then you're gonna lose your A7 Pawn
with another Tempo so probably grenade
six Rook takes A7 then you go back to C8
and here white has been crushing
Advantage after the move E5 wow now what
I was dreaming about that is for sure
cool okay interesting name to keep it uh
I think we should take a look at Wesley
rapid game because Wesley was not afraid
to grab a Pawn on B7
that was kind of a question right uh we
played night before and I was hinting at
compensation because of Knight C2 and
and Wesley said
show me
Bishop takes E5 concrete line
yeah
I I suppose after Rook B8 that's just
Queen C7 like like you're always
wondering when do I get in the tempo
Rook B8 right should I reach should I
take the bishop okay he took took Bishop
B5 now he's saying look you've got a
problem you can't just tickle my queen
right away so let's say Rook d8 which
one am I supposed
and that's the question right now you
have to agree to the trade of Queens
exactly
and here uh you know we're we're we're
mentioning how beautiful that night is
going to be on C4
um how should I do it in a way
so I
step aside so I could get the pond back
with Knight D3 route
ah and I take three too
ah sorry
that was you might still have a good
position though
yeah but that wasn't I at the end of the
day what I wanted it obviously was to
have a knight on C4
okay but uh
we do have this position on the board we
do have Rook d8
Can I by it should make Rook B1 now
because there's not ID3 yet ah thank you
for that thank you Nasi that's uh
that's an improvement uh much desired
Improvement and after Rook P1 well
let's see Escape somehow exactly I don't
think I do
Queen Sea Salad
oh I don't take the pump
right I I hide here
only when the pawn is on the board so in
this case yes nice okay I do you have to
I have to resist capturing upon are you
kidding me that you know that's hard
right I mean I understand it's like
backward moves you know it's just like
it's not what we do it's not what we
look at and it's strange because Queen
is still not really out it's stuck on A5
but it's just avoids repetition yeah it
avoids repetition but somehow that's a a
pretty decent Square it is after all
eyeballing things and you know it's all
about the night getting to C4 right once
the night gets seceded we can't really
get rid of black snide on B4 no so it
feels like our Queen's never getting out
of there
that's a long yeah never strong but it
you you're right at the moment it really
does feel like we're stuck and maybe
even for a long time but Bishop takes B5
a takes B5 and then it's easy for us to
become unstuck comes to A1 looking good
looking good for Wesley I must say uh
Lavon versus Anish uh we're a little bit
mystified because Anish basically said
take my Pawn on B7
Lavon said not interested
which is shocking but he played G4 and
um yeah so we have two Bishops versus
two knights well there goes the two
Bishops right there
and
first impressions are that black is
doing just fine
uh Anisha last night because black
Snyder on B6 does not look pretty good
temporarily but the Black Knight on B6
is blocking
um the pawn they're they're by defending
the pawn it's not that I'm going to play
C4 and take this Pawn anytime soon is
your Bishop so great let's egg play F6
and G5
kind of stuffing so that's a commitment
to go F6 G5 yeah well it's I I'm playing
this to literally stuff the bishop uh so
this diagonals now if my Pawn's on F6
you're not happy about that diagonal
right uh if my Pawn is on F6 and G5
you're not getting stuff
um we're looking for here guys rookie 4
is a very strong move for Levon Rook E4
now threatening Bishop B4 to trap the
queen
and this is actually very very bad
position for our Niche here it's very
difficult to defend now the pawn only
five what if I move the queen back let's
say to D6 yeah so he didn't play
actually but let's just continue on that
route before Queen D6 queen queen E3 and
now I'm attacking the pawn only five and
also threading the move so 97. 97.
take the pawn take the pawn
I thought I had 1995 Bishop to B4 that's
a oh that's that's awkward
gosh darn it yeah so he actually missed
opportunity for Levon because now after
the move Queen E3 I think is not that
much better because there is uh you know
you can exchange on E3 there is a knight
A4 move as well here so so I think a
missed Opportunity by him
maybe a big best opportunity actually
because yeah that that move Rook E4 uh
it
it's it's like you're trapping the queen
in the center of the board with the move
Bishop before and uh you you your eye
isn't looking for that type of a trap
Queen E3 uh does allow uh like you say
both Knight A4 as well as Queen trades
missed opportunity Wesley versus Richie
let's go again uh Rook
yeah just sidestepping Knight C2 again
Wesley is is looking at this and
uh it's important not to take the A7
Pawn to high unless you want to draw
unless you want to draw but to hide your
queen on A5 uh definitely Advantage
Wesley
uh Yan versus Magnus
turn off did anything change well it's a
pawn isn't it oh yeah there's an extra
Pawn
I mean that's all I do right yeah but
you're losing it because you don't have
B3 there is rookie three
to take C2 and King takes C1
I remember your milinski saying to me he
says yes sir
ninety percent of my chess is
calculating who's upon up with
90 yeah only only uh Bishop C1
probably still enough about that Rook
end game just rocked you too and yes I
agree so rookie three check as well as
Bishop takes B2 pardon me Bishop takes
B2 on magnus's agenda nothing is
happening for the world's number one uh
player mvl game
did get to play E4 and D5 yeah
so A4 structure we now have on 97 Bishop
e D5 Rook C1
um these positions you always always
mindful of these sacrifices aren't we
and by the way for those who are joining
us late first of all shame on you but uh
Magnus world's number one player he's in
a galaxy of stars how do we know that
he's tied for seventh
something you don't hear often no no not
in a 10 player tournament
like could be a Swiss right with uh even
then even then he tied for seven
and Duda is so litter he won both games
very nice games
precisely like yes perfectly played
yeah his accuracy was really commendable
and by the way Anish did play the move
find the move Knight A4 kind of a
present if you will uh
it still looks stressed but the one
doesn't look so happy either right both
players like both players unhappy
All Right Wesley versus uh Richie and
for Wesley an opportunity here VAR after
all should do that draw Magnus and
by the way that sounds so strange right
right you know Magnus who's playing
poorly you know uh should he draw Wesley
could potentially go in day one in time
for first absolutely yeah he's he's
slightly better here but uh there is
definitely some compensation here again
now repeat you cannot take the pawn on
A7 if you take the pawn then you you
know black will do the repetition and
immediately queen c77 of course Wesley
playing for a win here let's take a look
at some of the lines now after 27 so I
think the best thing to do is to force
this queen to go to A5 okay so bc8 now
Queen A4 Queen on A5 again it's out of
place there so it's not doing that much
and here you know you can uh consider
maybe to play the move G4 here you go
for some G4 ideas because white doesn't
have that many defenders in the position
here so one of the lines is Bishop takes
D7 Rook takes D7
and some potential ideas of swinging a
rook to G7 as well at some point so
Queen B5
now you know you have ideas like Queen
G7 here threatening to play G4 and uh
it's it's not easy because you have to
now come back you you win a pawn but you
spend a lot of time you know on coming
back now on E2 and here you just
continue with the move G-Force
trying to open up the position if you
take on G4 then F takes G4 and suddenly
both Rooks can go to the f file and try
to put some pressure on F2 the bishop is
very strong only five as well again it's
still a very complicated position but I
think something like this we might see
happening in this game
and just their head to head uh they
haven't played that many times but boy
it's sure been one-sided yeah Wesley has
four wins and five draws no losses wow
uh yeah I wouldn't have expected such a
one-sided uh
outing between these two fine players
Queen
A5
G5 which is enriches style to places yes
well also uh I always loved when I was
reading these books the Soviets would
make these annotations the move
fits the requirements of the position so
with the queen on A5 no matter how
temporarily temporarily displaced you've
got to do something you're pawned down
and G6 G5 fits the requirements of the
position of trying to open it up I
wanted to ask VAR about the move Knight
C4 as opposed to Bishop takes B5 and
Rook takes I mean I'm still leaving my
queen high and dry and I suppose we
would con continue G4 is that let's
let's take a look Queen takes A5 and
queen A5 G5 Knight C4 is this an
overreach by me Knight C4 let's see nice
before sorry you can play this move but
I think black will continue with the
move G4 yeah
and I more or less I have to take I
guess on G4 yeah take one G4 F takes G4
right and that Bishop
on E5 is scary but 92 kind of feels like
why it's being punished for having the
queen yes well that's what G5 does right
I mean it's it's sort of like it's a
double-edged sword
92 can run into a move G3 try to create
weaknesses on E3 yes oh that's grim
so if I saw this G5 g4id in this
position and that was Wesley I would
just go Queen B7 and repeat Queen D7 and
repeat instead of Queen A5 yes
it's not very comfortable yeah I played
sometimes these positions as white and
this the H the problem with the pawn on
H3 is just the hook and G4 G5 G5 G4
comes in and then you have to start
reacting to it so wow so there is
definitely some Contra play here for
Richie but I think he he needs to really
find his G5 G4 otherwise if Wesley
slowly consolidates he's got an extra
Pawn absolutely
oh a very very important game to our
standings jump to our uh another later
way Tasha's game you're right you know
Knights is still on F3 right that
temporary night right and here when we
left it the knights yeah there was an
inclusive move A7 A6 which I liked
because that move kind of suggests first
of all we're getting our Pawn out of hog
but it really suggests I want to play B5
and that was why redislav played A4 and
it was a inclusion of that move and I
left for a few moves but now it's back
it's back right
night is back very unpleasant don't have
three truly I can never take
no you don't want to allow Bishop takes
F3 Queen takes everything but the the
annoying part is not that f2f4 was an
immediate threat but once you play
Knight F3 I don't even I can't even
think about making a blunder like F4
because a G3 Pawn is saying in the
meanwhile Knight is also eyeballing an
opportunity uh to play Knight D4 how do
the engines evaluate this position far
because I have to tell you from a human
perspective
um it's very difficult at first you want
to believe in the two Bishops and your
extra Pawn in the center if you will but
I'm reluctant to say it's so cut and dry
yeah it's just equal at the moment here
you don't have that control of the
center that we see you know Whitehead
earlier here and especially this D4
square is giving black enough Contra
play here and not an easy position to
play for white because you have to watch
out for this move 94. for example here
you know Bishop he has to play like
Bishop B6 or Bishop E3 and after let's
say Bishop E3 which is a it's a logical
move uh black uh can play a move Bishop
f8
and at some point you want to bring the
bishop into the game here as well so
it's not an easy move to find Bishop but
uh just trying to see the idea and let's
say you continue with A5
and now you can play the move G5
and the the Knight on C3 is very passive
you don't have that many scores to go to
The Rook only two as well that don't
have any moves at the moment so you
really don't have that many moves so
white actually you know is trying to now
sacrifice the pawn here just to get some
activities for the pieces with the
Knight to go on e4 and again evaluation
is just zeros at the moment
thank you for that uh and by the way we
didn't see the move G5 by Richie a move
that we kind of felt
fit the requirements of the position
instead he played the move a a 7 A6 uh
asking why to declare and Wesley traded
an option to drop back with Bishop F1
and keep control of the white squares
maybe that was better
I don't know I VAR convinced me that the
trading light squared Bishops we could
left the E6 Square week so but I agree
with you Bishop F1 uh kind of keeping
you know an an extra Defender maybe not
so bad but I'm attracted to what Wesley
did which was to trade and put his
Knight on C4 something that we've been
kind of banging the drum for some time
not necessarily that I'm eager to play
the move F4 but if I do get to play F4
and we're also threading Knight B6 so oh
by the way so I had to move one of the
Rooks right okay so can I just see
uh oh maybe I'm tactically I'm allowing
Knight C2 in this weekend too much yes
well there is a problem guys in this
position we I think we need to take the
bishop only five because after let's say
move F4 here the bishop can go to F6 and
then let's say queen queen f8 and Bishop
d8 and the queen is going to get trouble
25.
I think it's very important to take the
bishop at this point already yeah to get
rid of the one piece that can attack the
queen queen takes A5 and then maybe just
Rook D2 and just and now uh you can play
uh Rook D2 yeah and again it's just it
shows about equal here this position
well again the queen on A5 if you don't
exploit her off-sightedness I I do see
F4 and E4 coming for white
uh in the very near future
but it's hard for black to start an
attack now without the bishop only five
without the other Bishop like a lot of
pieces have been traded so it just feels
like a pawn attack but you still play G5
with G5 here G4 and I can just still
imagine that black isn't without
attacking resources uh let's just
continue around MBL for a second we
played Knight A2 which I think was a
good move as well by the way
Knight A2 in order ah in this case first
of all this is still slow and we can
take
and get rid of
this guy on A6 and then where I think
tonight on before was bothering Wesley
more than the bishop on E5 yes yes
exactly Knight A2 well I must say once
you see the move
it looks good looks good and now Richie
needs to find the only move otherwise
he's in really big trouble here what's
the only move uh he needs to play the
move Rook A7
to protect A6 because after the exchange
of the knights A6 Pawn it's A6 Pawn is
going to fall so now and if Knight takes
before then you can take back Rook takes
before
that is
wonderful I mean I must say it it didn't
occur to me that you have to defend A6
but I mean it makes sense because for
the last 10 moves we've been living the
pawn unprotected on A7 right so we
thought it's just fine to live it like
that right
but that is uh
yeah that's a remarkable conception wow
and he's played it Rook A7 Bravo Richie
I mean alien chess
Rook A7
wow
so what they do evaluation here of our
zero zero zero
why are you gonna ask right
wow Rook a seven zero zeros
uh remarkable by the way uh just jumping
to the game of Magnus Carlson
uh it's a draw I understand four versus
three and is now three versus two
but
it goes to show that and magnus's body
posture says it all is like
why am I defendant yeah I'm suffering
why am I here uh I mean he comes in as
the highest rated player in classical
Blitz and Rapids and he is suffering he
lost his first game
um drew his second yeah in the second
game he didn't have any chances to play
for more Wesley just
nullified him absolutely and now well
suffering is time a factor so it seems
like a simple draw I actually don't have
access to the so that there we go on the
screen
Magnus has extra 20 minutes
say it again
so Magnus has 22 minutes right and Duda
has two minutes
so extra 20 minutes in a rapid game
that sounds excessive
it is but we also have this position
where neither of them really have to
think
true extra pawn and all that jazz but
ah remarkable yeah I think it will be a
quick draw
well I mean I would play Rook H5 I would
I would agree to trade off this A5 Pawn
for this B7 pawn and I agree that my
pawns on C3 and D4 are likely to make a
draw but with with my Rook on B7 I'll
play for C5 and I'll try to go after the
C6 Pawn so he played King King
C7 very cleverly uh ready to meet any
Rook check with King B8
by the way I think it went to another
game I think mvl has a very big
Advantage now okay and you can also join
the leaders or no I think he drew two he
drew two right so if he wins now he
would quickly jump yes higher
understandings okay when we saw we last
we kind of got the Knight G4 in and we
thought that white was enjoying a little
bit of a pull but Queen B5
that's posting up
Rook C6
and
so long as we're not losing this Pawn on
F5 we're really happy that we've got
command of the C file Canada has 36
seconds guys say what 36 seconds versus
14 minutes oh and Rook to C8 and why do
we love open files for our Rooks because
we get to invade and queen D Queen C2 to
C6 looks like a wonderful Invasion Queen
E6 quickly played sight once again the
times time so Daniel has 49 seconds
while MBL has 14 minutes so and that's
crashing position that's joyous and the
crushing position he can play Rook d8
here I think or queen B6 maybe he can
pick up some pawns for some reason I was
afraid that Rook C7 was a threat and
you're scaring my Rook forgetting the
fact that the Bishops do move backwards
and The Rook is defend it so you move
Rook d8 actually just threatens to just
pick up a piece so let's see
77 bucks
I'll take once
makes sense
and do something like that I want to
pick up eight five yes
I
and he's done there's nothing on the
king side right block doesn't have some
H5 ideas well that was the the
craftiness of mbl's King F1 it was
almost like preemptive strike you know
you're gonna play H5 but I'm I'm gonna
run with my king before
it explodes I see and he's played oh
much nicer move
uh Queen C8 pinning The Rook
the queen
intubating
well that's uh oh
consider that one yeah actually he
missed something even better guys if we
go back one move Queen C8 looks very
nice but it's it's actually losing some
of the advantage Rook takes D7 here yes
and when you capture back with the Rook
there's this beautiful move Rook C5
a winning winning the A5 Pawn With The
Rook yes okay otherwise H5 is coming
some control player from black but Rook
C5 would have been almost plus five here
for white oh that's five oh oh
Queen to C8 King G7 on the board again
one and let's jump quickly to Wesley
Richard game because I've heard some
updates that now rich is doing better
whoa let's see what happened we've left
it here Rook A7 Bravo take take check
Rook D2 so maybe let's check yeah we
left the B-2 Pawn on pre
hmm maybe that's the issue
Rook takes P2
can you help us out bar yeah
we think Magnus is about to make a
repetition and a draw
yeah
two extra pawns but you know this from
the Philadelphia position yeah
Jack kc8
I think you're gonna assist dominate on
the board
is that how they're gonna finish it C7
Rook H6 C6 okay kids
Rook take C6
if you take it you lose all right right
oh style now if C6 you just go down Rook
G1 yes exactly uh let's just show the
viewers what we're thinking we're
thinking C7 and we're thinking this very
nice move Rook H6 to stop the king from
coming so we go C6 Rook takes C6 genius
move uh offering
um a stalemate we don't see the board on
the screen oh sorry but oh Magnus is
going for cellmate he gave her blue and
check and now on King C6 he's gonna play
the V6 check okay
so King C6 Rook to B6 check King to D5
and Rook H6 right
yeah D6 now yes it's not a mad Rook
you know I'm I'm familiar with mad Rook
from studies but I can't recall having
one in my own game ever I had a similar
end game against Anish giri long time
ago that I defended it
same idea I cut it eventually I cut it
on a six rack and then
you know he also still made the tent I
don't want to say ever but it doesn't in
me a game doesn't immediately pop in the
mind
as we do expect this game to go to a
draw let's jump again to the Wesley
versus uh Richie rapport
because uh
Rook ab7 uh kind of threw some stuff
away we were the a6a5 oh and ndl was
much much much more exciting
I think we have a Checkmate coming
oh it's already over oh poor dioc is uh
tough start for the terrible start uh
Rook h8
G6 Bishop takes D5 oof
that's a big blow
uh and beautiful queen takes H4 in this
game Western versus report guys there
was a very important concept I think
what the Richie missed uh if we go back
uh to the move
Rook ab7 that's the inaccurate move yeah
yeah uh what he had to do in this
position is to play the move uh A5
because now what you're trying to do is
you really want to trade Queens in this
position so you want to play the move
Queen E7 next and you go to this end
game with you're down upon but you're
actually much better because A4 B2 D5
all these spawns are going to be weak
now and you're forcing the exchange of
the queens and even even instead of A6
you could he could have played the move
Queen E7
forcing the queen back on A5 and then
Queen C7 and this end game despite being
down upon is actually a big Advantage
for black because you have the open file
the pressure on the B2 A4 King F6 some
point maybe King E5 and you're the only
one who is pressing wow I've wow
wouldn't have guessed it Rook ab7 Queen
a a queen A8 Rook takes B2 by the way
Magnus has drawn he will be very very
dissatisfied with his two draws in one
loss for the today
conversely
dude will be very happy two wins in one
draw and that's the way the Polish
audience loves it a queen takes B2 Rook
F1
um
Wesley so many people watching them live
yeah people going in and out at all
times I bet it's not super quiet for the
players no no
um see C4 uh could you just help me out
here guys I'm a pawn Grabber so it's
natural for me to ask so three Queen
takes C3 just C3 and it's gonna be uh
Perpetual I think at the end what is the
Perpetual so Queen C6 Queen C6 right C2
and you gotta go Queen B1 right okay so
something like G5
takes takes checks right now don't I
have a pipette at the end of the day
there's King H6 but
so if Queen D7 check engage six
not quite sure 45 I'll take all Queen is
seven King gauge six Queen H4
the bright not
uh queen of eight because of King H5
it's yes exactly G5 check King takes and
this is the Perpetual do not be seduced
by Queen f8 but rather Queen H4 and this
is the Perpetual that's for uh was
mentioning and by the way the players
are very quickly uh oh we got King H2 we
don't have a G4 on the position
but
sorry let me just refresh my board
please I'll be right back a few moves
played we do take Queen B1 now King H2
C2 Queen C4
and
Queen B1 let's see
[Music]
it's a little bit Queen C8 Quincy yes so
oh yeah with a check
but still Queen F1 no I I'll have the
prepared Queen B7 check
there's nothing I can do I know it's
weird right
okay H6 right
yeah and queen E7
Queen takes F2 doesn't it uh Queen takes
F1 Queen takes King H6 Queen E7 we're
setting up the classical and we've got
sorry Rook B4 was played Queen C7 check
on the board
and King H6
for quick and King H6 on the board
um varm I I mean I'm tempted to say draw
but it's still Wesley who has to play
accurately right uh yes he's playing
Acura Queen D6 is an excellent move oh
because Rook on before you come before
hanging you don't have time to promote
right
no it's time a factor uh minute and a
half and Richie has three minutes
she has three minutes Roxy for played
and now we're gonna I believe we're
gonna see the move Queen f8
check
forcing the king to take a walk up the
board
and then Queen F7 probably
Queen f8 Shack or queen E7 King H5
I mean
wait a minute are you walking into a
meeting
yeah F3
oh oh F3 C1 your g-pawn is pinned Oh I
thought you were gonna have to take with
the queen on C1 so I could play G4 okay
uh Wesley's just did not play F3 instead
he went Queen E7 gift knee the pawn on
uh H7
and let's jump uh to Warsaw as one a
Christian is with magnets
Magnus first of all welcome back to the
grandchester always a pleasure to have
you around this is the first official
games after abdicating the title give us
your initial feelings
um after the first few moves yeah I
haven't really uh
uh you know played or study just Parts
recently so it was kind of showing
um but at least I set it the like a
little bit in the last couple rounds so
uh it's not a it's not a disaster but
yeah overall uh overall it's really
rusty and we started with the Polish in
Poland how did you come to that that
idea yeah it was something actually uh
Peter suggested a couple days ago and I
was like yeah sure
um so when you make such an opening
choice that obviously increases the
variance quite a bit
um and uh
I don't think like
against an unprepared opponent I don't
think it's that bad but unfortunately I
didn't
I didn't remember what I was supposed to
do and then my position was pretty bad
early on like I suspect probably after
that I had some chances to uh to come
back a little bit but it was always
difficult and he deserved to win but um
yeah uh polish and Bowen didn't didn't
work definitely not the start that you
envisioned but in the second game it
felt like vintage Magnus you were
oppressing him in uh the late middle
game did you feel like you had any
chances at any point well first of all I
thought I was better from the opening
and then
um like five minutes later I was
struggling to equalize so I don't think
it was was vintage but yeah I did feel
like I was trying to I was starting to
play well at some point also from a
psychological point of view starting to
put a better pressure then at some point
he found a very critical move there
Quincy eighth and after that I sort of
have to I have to exchange screens and
then it looks like
could be promising for white still but
it probably probably wasn't but it's
it's typical typical Wesley
um that he
um he usually defends pretty well when
he's
when he's up against it and we know that
you are a man that generally likes to uh
do some physical workouts before your
games you go skiing occasionally I saw
you posted uh a soccer photo with
Christian pulisic was that from today or
did you go to the exercise I didn't know
that I posted that okay no no that was
from from London last last week that's
good too and good to know okay Magnus uh
go get your rest we'll see you tomorrow
thank you thank you Christian thank you
Magnus jumping into the game with Wesley
versus Richie because we have some
really really weird ships shocking
updates right here instead of the move
D6 there is an incredible checkmating
idea that starts with the move G4 and
Wesley could have had the tables all in
his favor I think this is still winning
right now it's still the case but in a
different way yeah and he did play G4
but in a different way
for check
King H5 so when can he push D7 that's
the key well I guess right now
you can play d72
queen queen D2 and well how do I
continue
Queen D2
Queen E5
and white shark ended his game in a draw
yes we do let's jump back to Wesley's
game D7 on the board and the point is
Queen D2
D7 was a mistake now I think it's a draw
after Queen D2 so how was white winning
uh let me show you uh instead of the
move D7 uh yeah instead of the move um
uh D7 he should have played the move
Queen F3 check first okay kg5 King G5
and then you play the smooth King H3 oh
come on
13.4 mate keeping H1 under control and
threatening mate yes that's incredible
wow 25 right yeah
and then you play D7
wow and the red cannot go to D1 and
cannot go to ca to stop the pawn why
can't I play Queen E6 check Queen E6
check and I play King G3
and now if you check on E5 I have Queen
F4 check and after we exchange I take
with the check and promote the pawn let
me just interrupt ourselves and to say
that Queen D2 is played and I think they
repeat it a few times a few times of
repetition
I'm winning chances but not easy to see
for
sure continues but wait
wait wait what's going on after King H4
is it the King still getting mated King
H4 looks like a blunder King G2 King G4
was necessary
he played Queen E4 check but Wesley had
King G2 didn't he
oh my gosh after King H4 Queen f8 was
the winning move Queen f8 oh because he
can't take on descendants 2 attacking H6
and if you take only seven Queen H6 and
queen H3 I mean those are impossible
Lines no time on the clock and it does
look like the players have a repetition
but if he finds Queen f8 here wow that
would be a wow
the queen f8 is a very optically very
pleasing move it defends F2 something
threatens mates
he found it wow honestly what a hero of
my Peak right now yeah
what a hero Queen f8
unblowable unbelievable he's threatening
the queen he defends F2 but he's also
threatening Queen H6 and queen H3 made
and Richie stopped yeah Richard just
slipped it really just slipped he should
have just played KNG foreign
if the king is on G4 instead of H4 right
but this the the the problem is that
we're just threatening meat
Queen takes H6 and queen H3 made and
that's what Richie is facing and he
doesn't like it he's looking at the
clock what's the times
um Wesley has 45 seconds and Richard has
mini 20. apologies uh we're being told
that Lavon is actually winning and I'm
sure that's an exciting game but this
game
is huge uh because if Wesley Winchester
he will tie with Duda for the lead I'm
speechless that these guys can find only
moves like this with like 20 seconds on
the clock I know it's remarkable they
are the calculations ability defy
understanding not to mention it's the
last round of the day they're also tired
hello absolutely
but uh Richie's King H4 was the blunder
right for King G4 would have been King
G4 Etc yes yeah
and sorry once again the time for
foreign
Rook H1
and now Queen of the game but it looks
pretty winning I'm sure King G4
is that a quick finish here with King
Gage
two by the way this was the only way
Richie could continue the game right
otherwise it just immediately loses
right
and by the way Lavon did win his game
and he's tied for first and he's tied
for first and once again my picks are
just ah they're dropping terribly
um
by the way uh I'm pawns up but it's
really strange it's awkward right
that I don't have a very I I don't want
to play Queen H2 I want to play
something active but I want to play King
age so still threatening Queen H3 mate
that's Queen C7 check is the problem
right Queen A6 okay looking good
okay so check we can just engage through
get out we protect A4
but it's King F3 King F3 is the best
chance for reaching mate King F3
threatens major two
I guess I have queen of Secrets
and by the way King F3 on the board
Queen F6 check just as you and King E2
just as you predicted uh their check no
that's this is a prepared
it's still no I I have King G2 now now I
can walk up the board towards the king
age so King H2 and I walk up the board
towards the g-pawn
10 seconds for Wesley King H2
as expected
so now we've Queen now to draw Queen G4
Queen G4 is a drone
yes
this is impossible
oh my gosh so we should have Wesley
played instead Queen takes G5 was the
only move and King takes F2 it's it's
probably technically winning but it's
not easy to win the end game yeah well
two extra pawns wait but Queen G4 can I
just play Queen
and then that's the idea you take on D4
you exchange planes and then you play
King F2
and then you're threatening G4 G3 and if
you play King H3 Queen oh he didn't play
that he didn't play Queen G4 he is
missed his uh chance there Queen E4 and
S3 F3 by Wesley I thought oh this is
this is just winning now
and now Queen takes E3 I assume I've got
a check this is going to be a long game
well if you go
uh Queen takes E3 Queen takes B2 she
decided to take the a pawn okay
it should be easier to win with the two
connected pawns right one of the crazy
things was uh John Nunn he showed that
in the table base sometimes having two
connected past Pawns
black king would have to be in front of
the Pawns
not behind right by the way Queen A2
what did the table basis tell us uh why
does one enrich white is winning
and E4 is the best move here E3 E4 does
it matter if
the where the king is you can also play
Queen F4 here but I think it makes sense
to start pushing the E Pawn right it
doesn't matter where the king is if the
king were on A1 or something like that
but if black king was an E8 would that
be a draw no I think it's actually it's
only a draw if you have a h and G Pawn
that's the only with the central plans I
don't think you can make a draw because
you're just not going to have that many
squares King will have more squares to
go to by the way Queen G3 that just sets
up
truly
yeah Richie just pushed it too hard he
he should have just allowed the
repetition uh when Wesley was trying to
just repeat and now E5 f4 on Wesley's
agenda time trouble you don't have time
to make decision if you should just take
the draw or push and you just go with
your gut yeah sometimes you pay for it
exactly uh King E3 uh Richie was a
little bit unsure
and uh if F4 came and that looks really
really a good move
as the queen is ready after King E4 to
go Queen F3 check
right King D4 and then I can go King to
G4 G3 start making steady advances over
there trying to play for Queen G4
um
by the way clock times once again uh 40
seconds against 20 seconds 40 seconds
for Wesley yes as he's just played the
move King F2 with the idea of of pushing
the the black king away with Queen E3
check
putting the queen on e4 so you can go
Queen F5 Queen F5
Queen day one
yeah cutting the king of further yeah
yeah go away go away go away and
prepping King E3
oh
sorry I at first I thought Queen C2
check was that no it was King F4 right
yes exactly Richie's still in the game
It's Tricky yeah Western needs to go
King G3 this is very important plan
exactly and to prepare Queen G4
exactly he'll figure it out because
there's no other way to improve right uh
you you you're tempted to throw in Queen
E3 check for whatever reasons but I do
agree that King
G3 followed by Queen G4 makes the most
sense
so much
I like to test how in to convert this it
looks like an easy one but it's never
easy
these guys they also always find the way
of making it practically so difficult
a couple of checks from Black
okay Wesley picking up time on the clock
he's gonna go King H4
and then cover it with Queen H5
7 exactly
exactly
I mean it's it's slow but it is
incremental progress you can see that
would you know we're we're going up the
board we're making more inroads and at
certain moment we'll be able to play E6
as well right
so Queen check
inviting Queen G5
yes Queen G5 Queen H7 King G4 yes
exactly
at some point black queen will probably
drop to the first rank to try to give
checks from behind
I assume white white queen or black
screen will drop to the first rank to
give checks from behind but of course
it's still completely winning for white
how do you get to the first rank though
when I see him that not easy
not sure how we do it
wow it takes two more stress to get to
them just to get to the first rank right
it's it's not it's not so easy yeah it
was the game time he has more than a
minute now
12 seconds once again we see very very
practical Wesley repeating positions
just you know to Garner those extra
seconds
yep Queen F5 uh Queen's one of the
guiding principals in Queen and pawn and
games the centralize your queen
Queen on H5 doesn't make a great
impression Queen it still looks like we
allow a lot of checks let's say queen G8
um can I walk towards your queen
King H5 yeah well he's played oh he's
preparing Queen E6
F5 right because finally I can get a
king of pawning game Queen E6 F5
and maybe coin A2 but
well then I'll just go E6 and it should
be winning yeah it does look like f5's
VAR F5 absolutely absolutely
and Wesley says absolutely yeah
and now your idea of checking from
behind but we do have time to get in a
queen F4 check right just keeping that
question and push the pawns although I
do I need it E6 is the tempting
better to be safe
E6
let's get that guy going okay kg5
first okay
uh presuming Queen G2 check is being met
by King F6
I could do queen G4 because if you
exchange coins and take on E5 you still
have the same way good point
good point
plays Queen G2 inviting Kim G6 no maybe
F6
this goes on E6 it is Queen G7 it's
probably also an input
I'm telling you I would be king G6 and
thinking that I'll be able to meet Queen
check with Queen G5 and you know just
keep my king beautifully safe probably
everything is winning exactly
as we're making sure before he pushes
the pawn because it's something you
can't take back exactly such a
commitment F5 F6 bar agreed yes that was
a goodie yes absolutely he's playing
very very precisely here
not allowing
King E6
King E6 I guess I can just play Queen G5
one second and he flagged
uh
wow oh Jeff Wesley wow well what an
eventful uh three three rounds let's
jump uh to Warsaw with Christian and
Duda
thanks uh Yasser we are here with the
defending Champion yanashi staff uh Duda
after a dominant first day two and a
half out of uh three or five points with
um the two for a victory two points for
a victory one for a draw scoring system
congratulations tell us a bit about your
initial feelings about this day one yeah
thank you yeah it's been for sure a
really good day for me
um yeah I don't think I could really
expect more from the games so
um yeah I'm very positive to you know
start over in Warsaw and you really
started strong with a big victory
against Anish take us through this game
it felt like Anish came swinging he was
really looking for a fight I mean he's
like a bit sadistic and he's playing
this G6 you know all the time against me
um
you know but in Rapid like all the time
G6 and why didn't he televised me with
his girlfriend and I'm like switching
lines and all the time and
um yeah I mean this time I mean I have
Again Play This F34 but just to be the
game without any you know Fury that was
the point but um I don't think
I don't think this position is like uh
you know maybe I'm not worse but I can
be possibly better in here because
um
like uh black um doesn't have a knight
so now his pieces are you know
have more space yeah yeah I mean and
he's not struggling with space so but
perhaps still struggling with the C8
Bishop a little bit yeah I mean also
like neither is five also Knight D7 at
some point was possible I think like or
I means yeah here or even I mean I mean
you know
yeah move the queen somewhere and only
the 97 yeah I mean I mean I mean
everything everything is kind of okay
for him when did you feel like he
started going astray yeah I didn't like
B5 actually I had missed it so I was
very very unpleasant moment when he
played B5 per second but then I realized
that after the 90s B5 Rook B8 he
probably and
assumption probably forgot about the A4
inclusion because if I play nhc3 Then he
has Bishop A6 yeah and like uh it's huge
for actually winning here uh foreign
and see what to do here because black is
very active also like Queen F6 heavy and
there are some tricks like Bishop H3 for
example in some positions like uh I
don't know really one
uh let's take okay Knight takes well
okay sure yeah but I was considering
pontics actually maybe he can also start
with Queen F6 yeah and yeah yeah that's
really nice yeah you cannot take because
now you lose yeah it's the idea that you
have to always to be heard about him
this is white so the opening of the file
very cool very cool Motif and uh yeah
and actually I I sort of like my queen
A1 but um
yeah I mean I mean it was uh
it was just you know like you've been
only just just Uncle benoni game
basically so yeah uh here I thought I
mean because I uh ended I wasn't so sure
I mean can can we move a little bit yeah
because this position is like very very
weird uh here of course he of course
started fishing for repetition yeah we
should do traditional Basics uh I I
didn't allow him to do that I mean I I
didn't put Ruby one back and
um yeah and this position is very very
weird actually I mean 1993 okay it looks
logically had to play the 19 before
another neither one I thought F5 is very
interesting actually for him and EF and
Ani before yeah Rook takes F5 Queen B1
is initial I think but um that makes
sense and yeah because Ruby is also on
the agenda yeah and he can really move
his knife
yeah but night before and I mean this is
just unclear position
I mean of course this F5 is a bit loose
I mean his King is a bit loose but um
you know probably has to do it yeah yeah
he was considering it but um yeah it's
difficult you have to you know pick
something and it's difficult sometimes
you have to decide yeah one option and
after and here actually I was kind of
liking my position but um
um
yeah I thought because here I wanted to
like play G4 Bishop D2 Bishop C3 and
basically win the final F6 or at least
you know uh make him you know different
the spawn all the time not allowing any
active uh play but um I think yeah but
that's definitely right yeah but I uh
like sort of didn't see I mean it's
evaluated Knight C2 because it's um
I mean here at least he has this like
you know uh this queen Aid move I have
to move back here and here it's like
um it's just unclear yeah I think I mean
okay
but you know in uh when you have two
minutes yeah it's like a completely
different story yeah anyone's game
almost and here I really like the idea
really like like the idea of training
diets that's why I played lips from C3
with the idea of 92 but I also sort of
forgot about this queen D1 A4
um yeah it was it was strong for him
because after 92 there is A3
and uh
it's annoying actually yeah because the
spawn is suddenly very dangerous yeah
becoming becoming dangerous yeah that
was his best chance and you know maybe
even more than equality for for black he
didn't find it then he took over and
very nicely executed the end game
Advantage
um congratulations one of the things
that we really saw was the support and
energy coming from the crowd here in
Warsaw did you feel that as well after
your second game against the ark
everybody started applauding we don't
see this very often in chess right yeah
it's like all tradition I would say
um yeah it's very nice especially when
you win the game not lose
um yeah I mean what can I add do you
feel like you have a home court
advantage compared to all these other
players
I mean it's nice yeah but um you know
when I'm focused on chess I kind of
don't remember I'm playing in North also
so
um
yeah but I like the venue here and yeah
I mean you know I said once as I said in
Korea I think yeah once you
you know have a good tournament then
in some place and you're always like or
estimated so yeah yeah it's the case for
me I think well there's definitely the
good history following you in this venue
congratulations for a good first day and
we'll see you tomorrow
thank you Christian congratulations dude
as we see our standings nasty do the
honors right we have three co-leaders uh
Wesley saw Livonia
with
show my nationalistic colors uh go USA
and then uh with four points we have mvl
and Dorado slavoitashek who upset Magnus
in the first round he's very happy then
with I think 50 is Richard Robert yeah I
think lost to Wesley that drops him to
50 Cent and Magnus Carlson in the
seventh place
yeah well at Bucharest we got used to
saying world champions and challengers
in the bottom half of the table now
world number one in the bottom half of
the table
and with one point we have
carolershipiri and an unfortunate day
for diac he didn't get any points today
yeah that's a real real real challenge
as we take a look at our uh choices
what's going on
laughs
and
um
uh wait a minute wait a minute does that
even count uh very nice uh selection and
uh again I just want to say that for the
first round
pardon me for the first day we saw an
amazing number of uh results absolutely
and I just love the opening choices
right such exciting games
and stuff like that some really really
good stuff uh let's jump to Warsaw a
Christian with a guest
playing at a home a rather slav
definitely a great way to start with a
game against a former world champion
Magnus Carlsen and what a victory that
was tell us a bit about that game and
how did you approach the opening after
he surprised you let's say with the
Polish opening yeah yeah actually he
surprised me but
it wasn't a surprise
as I expected a surprise I didn't really
know if it will be some sort of a benoni
or something like that but then when he
played B5 I just thought okay let's play
let's do some normal moves but my
Approach was to play active chess and
this this is what I what I thought gave
me
gave me a victory because I uh I played
actively especially this move uh D5 we
can just take a look at the game yeah I
thought that when he went Bishop E7 if I
don't do anything uh fast he will he
will just go D6 and castle and obviously
I'm uh better but I thought that after
D5 I'm at the site which is uh playing
for like uh if you want to punish yeah
this opening not like that because he's
very very uh
strong of course but when you see
something like this you
don't want to go for some
maneuvering game because if you can go
D5 and obviously it looks very nice at
first so I thought that why not we had a
full uh audience there so I thought
let's play something let's go for it
yeah for them
and uh yeah after after that I thought
that Visa page six was uh important to
stop shortcastle and when he went Rook
G8 uh Bishop E3 back because now there
is no option to uh sarcasm and uh this
position was very very bad but uh but
then he was defending tenaciously of
course he's probably one of the best
defenders yeah yeah and uh yeah I mean
then then after Bishop of six this
position
I really liked but then after Knight H5
I realized that I have to defend F6 pawn
and I didn't really see exactly how and
that's why I went to Queen C3 and after
Rook d8 was very uh important moment
because my move
uh are you free looks like something
which doesn't really strike as a good
move but I didn't really see a better
one and the idea is that he is
threatening before before so let's say
you go G3 here yeah if I go something
like G3 he goes before Queen E5 and now
he goes D6 and I have to go back let I
mean let's say here and then after
Knight F6 at least he got his these are
not clear yeah yeah yes that's why
that's why I went for this A3
which doesn't look uh
impressive but uh also to
it felt that Magnus simply here he
doesn't have active moves so that's why
I thought I can afford it and then after
uh G3
uh
he went G5 around here I wasn't sure
because uh obviously with uh engine is a
very very simple also I uh obviously I
knew that I'm winning so but you're also
getting down on time and that's that was
a problem no pressure yes yes yes
especially that after uh Rook G5 this is
the moment I really wasn't sure how to
proceed because obviously it looks
excellent probably there are like many
many moves but you have to go for one
yeah which is you have options yes yes
yes right now sometimes it's uh not
ideal and uh I decided to go for uh
Bishop D3 probably the best move yeah
yeah rookie five and Knight F5 and uh
the thing is that I'm losing F6 pound
but there are so many threads
uh after a queen before
that I didn't really see how he can
defend especially that after D6 Queen C3
uh F6 is hanging I thought during the
game that maybe he could play something
like Knight G8 but obviously if you have
to play Knight Jade
you know things went wrong very very
wrong uh yeah yeah but I thought that uh
when he went B5 I actually made a very
good uh
um
[Music]
choice that I should play active because
obviously if I would play some normal uh
game
um we would maneuver and in the long
game obviously Magnus there are not so
many players who can play against him so
I thought that I should go all in and
this worked out and it wasn't
that's a hard in a sense that obviously
D5 is a is an idea which actually looks
very very nice so that was a great
decision initial decision in game one
and that definitely gave you a boost of
confidence after that I think you defeat
you defend it quite well against Richie
absolutely no problems with the black
pieces definitely a successful day one
for you for sure and we'll see you
tomorrow thanks guys thank you Christian
and indeed and the standings talk about
an exciting day one once more remind our
viewers
right we have uh three co-leaders Wesley
so Lebon aronian and young Christoph
Tuda winning two games today right then
we have MPL and radoslav with plus one
score uh 50 Richard Robert and uh minus
one yeah
again uh the rapid chests are double
points but I will mention that he was he
sent in a good mood even though he
started with a loss yeah he just said
that he hadn't been working hard on
chess it looked like he'd been working
hard on a surfing Beach Bum approach but
yeah we'll see if you can climb back
into the tournament for uh final
thoughts of a very eventful day one
absolutely guys very exciting day I'm
glad my pick is doing really well Devon
you know he's extremely strong in this
format very very experienced so he's
definitely playing good chess and Wesley
as well you know winning that game
against Richie was very impressed
impressive dude is playing great and
should be very exciting games we have a
lot of decisive games in particular
looks like white is winning a lot of
games and I counted at least six wins
six or seven wins for white so I'm
looking forward to tomorrow's action and
hopefully we'll see the Magnus play
Magnus play much better and we're gonna
go to Poland to our friends Anastasia
and Christian
slow day for a Magnus definitely but I
have to say we've been having a lot of
fun here in Warsaw a lot of exciting
chess and the crowd is just absolutely
incredible and I want to ask you
Anastasia about that you've been uh
hanging around the playing Hall quite a
lot you've been spending some time with
the players as well tell us about your
day
a day and you are
and you show up today and you know it
was very funny that all players they
have to give autographs after on the way
to go out of this building so it was so
funny like Magnus was walking on this
red carpet and then like huge crowd you
know was waiting for him hundreds of
people wanted his autograph and of
course he couldn't make it all but he
really has spent like maybe like 10-15
minutes to signing the postcards and you
know everything we could find they could
find and I mean it was really nice and
so many people were waiting for him it
was also nice simultaneous exhibition
which was given by kiril nations of
Ukrainian boy who won yesterday the game
in the symbol and today he was given the
symbol to local players so we have this
very nice Fun Zone nearby and many
people just come and play chess and
enjoy their time and I wanted to remind
to all of our viewers not to forget to
subscribe and follow our social media
accounts of grandchester or St Louis
chess club Instagram Twitter Facebook of
course you should so you will find lots
of materials there some really some
short interviews also with Maximo
Telegraph and which I have done just
after the third round because you also
have quite good tournament so it was
really nice it was fun day what about
you Christian and speaking of Magnus we
discussed this at the beginning of the
show as well it definitely felt like he
was happy his energy was definitely
positive and even after you know not
starting
as his usual self with victories he lost
one drew a couple he was still happy
even during the interview he was nice
relaxed I believe that actually I
remember him losing first rounds in
Rapid World rapid championships before
so I think maybe it's like he has this
short like slow start but still it's
just the beginning I'm sure that
tomorrow he might show a completely
different result remember in Croatia
also he started slowly and then you know
step by step it was getting better and
better so I still kind of believe that
he might do really well in this event he
definitely knows how to to handle this
type of slow starts we have a lot of fun
and exciting just ahead of ourselves and
yeah I cannot wait for this tournament
to unfold guys back to us chess fun in
Warsaw that's what it's all about let's
see very impressive uh day one and once
again it was great fun uh calling the
auction with you and bar thank you
everyone for joining us tell your
friends where you're hanging out and in
the meanwhile we'll see you all tomorrow
see you tomorrow
thank you
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited